Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ey, keiner meckert über meinen Big Brain Desktop.
Es war nur eine Sekunde, ich musste mal glaube ich den Chat refreshen.
Du brauchst einen Startscreen, das ist richtig, also Flo ich hoffe du hast wieder den Chat
zurück geschafft.
Die Musik ist ein bisschen weihnachtlich, 30 Sekunden gesperrt, 30 Sekunden das Niedrigste
was geht, Mario Galaxy Beste, uns refreshen, ich seh kurz den Chat nicht, 7 Head, genau,
ein Head, wir sind so Big Brain, da reicht der Bildschirm gar nicht für, so, wisst ihr
was wir heute machen, nix, ich hab absolut keine Ahnung, aber ich hab festgestellt,
es ist schon 20 Uhr, wenn ich jetzt den Stream nicht anschmeiße, dann stream ich schon gar
nicht mehr, deswegen hab ich jetzt einfach den Stream angemacht, hab nix vor, gar nix,
äh, ja das hab ich mir überlegt, dass wir um 22 Uhr gucken können, aber 22 Uhr gucken
können, der Vortrag geht ja noch mal über ne Stunde, das ist mir ein bisschen spät,
den Vortrag gucken wir uns morgen zusammen an, äh und zwar den hier, mein B klemmt immer
noch wegen dem Saft, ich hab mir jetzt die Tastatur übrigens bestellt hier, ne, Moment,
hat man das nicht so geschrieben, ne, C, 3, ah, ja, Bahn, Mining, also ich hab mir jetzt
die Tastatur bestellt, die wir uns hier angeguckt haben im Stream und zwar hier die, die, die
da mit, ähm, die da, mal gucken wie die ist, ich mein zurückschicken kann ich sie immer
noch, ja, weiß nicht, ich bin mal gespannt, ähm, sie wird auf jeden Fall besser sein
als meine K95, das bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, zumal die jetzt hier auch noch klemmt.
Ja, ich bin mal gespannt, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
ja, absolutely, ich bin verwirrt, meine bestellhistorie zeigt etwas anderes an als was ich bestellt
aber b79 nütte k k meine bestellhistorie zeigt irgendwie was anderes an aber das ist das gleiche
oder ja warum zeigt meine bestellhistorie was anderes an als auf der seite angezeigt wird
so jebait am werk oder was ist da ich bin jetzt echt ah nee ich glaube das liegt einfach daran
weil der andere browser komplett auf englisch eingestellt ist übrigens wisst ihr was mir
gerade einfällt was ich was ich schon lange immer im hintergrund zählte aber eigentlich
nie verwende was ich mir schon in seiner ganzen weile mal wieder angucken möchte der der
wibaldi browser wieder jetzt mittlerweile ist ah yes klassische musik genau excellent
für viele ist wibaldi ein komponist und kein browser für alle excellent klassiker
ich wollte den schon mal eine weile wieder ausbauen können wir uns gerade mal angucken was sich da
getan hat mal gucken ob wir den auch hier ordentlichen zählen können oder ob wir den
sonst zählen müssen schauen wir mal die waldi will in zukunft keine agent information mehr
übergeben an die webseite weil die sich ausgegrenzt fühlen verstehe ich nicht
beto normale version das sind die aktuelle version
2 9 kommen wir installieren das so
da steht 2 9 da steht 2 10 excellent größere versionen immer besser
meine klassische musik ändert nicht mit exe sondern mit punkt bat sind hier unter windows
da muss das wenn schon gleich betsch sein was heißt die wibaldi browser
verschleit identität hier zeig mal her
warum tragen java entwickler brillen
was ist das ich will das gar nicht das hat schon downloaded except alles kein problem ja ich
weiß an die da ist das eigentlich richtig schlecht nein wir wollen es erst mal nicht
als die fortsetzen ok wie weil die browser verschleiert seine identität ist erst mal
nicht verkehrt achso aktiv das wird das meinst du mit die fühlen sich ausgegrenzt
achso von daniel berger ich wusste gar nicht dass er für die ct schreibt oder für heise so
nach dem motto wenn die webseite erkennt das ist wie waldi ist und funktioniert nicht richtig
genau ja gut es haben viele webseiten viele webseiten haben wir mittlerweile diesen einen
diese einplendung so nachdem auch so ihr browser ist veraltet machen sie was anderes das ist
eigentlich die sinnvolle maßnahme ja ok what's new guck mal was man what's new in vielleicht
auch einfach auf englisch also read more ah yes verstehe no strings attached ach das
ist die geschichte hier ohje da haben sie aber ganz schön viel dazu geschrieben wie
viel views kriegt so denn wie waldi video eigentlich den tausend scheinen schon mal
okay hatte sie nicht so wahnsinnig mich würde interessieren wie verbreitet die benutzung
ist ich habe den ja schon vor jahren mal probiert und fand den auch richtig gut aber danach
irgendwie hatte ich ihn die ganze zeit nur noch installiert aber nie wirklich großartig
verwendet ok ich muss jetzt noch mal kurz auf features mal einfach gucken was die für
ok also ja features warum gucken wir uns das eigentlich im chrome an wir können uns einfach
im browser selbst angucken werden auch ein bescheuern wenn andersrum oder ok also wie
waldi features more flexible flexibility more control das auch nicht schlecht es gibt ja
jede menge so komische programmierer flachwitze wir könnten uns mal eine runde links hier
angucken no ich habe das einmal erlaubt weil ich nicht aufgepasst habe und dann hat mir
reddit jeden tag wenn ich den browser aufgemacht hat irgendwelche top sachen geschickt moment
was ist eigentlich mit der seite los die seite ist im arsch oh yes i agree oh nee da ist kein
blokker dabei ist ich hab gehofft dass ich da nicht blokker dabei es kann blokker dabei
mein mein blok da müssen wir ein tag gut da kann man bestimmt einfach chrome zeug immer
noch installieren auto adblock extension wie waldi browser install adblock chrome chrome
extension wer hätte das gedacht origin nie heißt auch nicht blok es heißt ja auch blok
adblock plus früher hat man immer adblock plus verwendet das war so eines der ersten
großen dinger die da hatten dann irgendwann sehr negativen ruf weil sie quasi werbung
durchgeschleust haben jetzt haben wir exzellent exzellent blokker ok also was was haben wir
denn hier schönes deny ich finde es übrigens auch schön dass die seite standardmäßig
dargesehnt ist ok google trying to be helpful how to initialize sex in japan ist doch gut
also das ist genau die reinfolge wie das den normalen menschen interessiert ja der will
erst mal wissen wie er zum zug kommt und danach will er wissen wie jeder normale normal
denkende mensch direkt im anschluss kommt wie leg ich in java an doch ganz logisch darauf
kommt dass das irgendwie abwegig ist als erstes jedes lebewesen denkt als erstes an essen
schlafen unterkunft und sowas ja aber direkt danach ans fortpflanzen und danach gleich
wie man java raise anlegt warum ist die musik eigentlich so laut ein bisschen leiser machen
gut ich finde auch nicht alles lustig war sie der aufreiter posten
ja gut das ist das ist halt so das ist halt tatsächlich sehr ähnlich
und das ist tatsächlich lustig
zwitsch mason sechs monate boar big brain sup nice dankeschön
nein noch nicht mal stimmt gar nicht richtig echter
das ist auch nicht schlecht
aber man muss dazu sagen ist aber in java logik das halt so
in sie schaap ist das übrigens nicht so
wenn man gerade auf das ein unterschied die b meinungen heute bleibt also nur wenn ich
sehr fit bin in sie schaap geht das
da kannst du strings wirklich gegeneinander checken und er checkt nicht ob die objekts
gleich sind sondern ob der inhalt gleich ist
ja zeitzonen ist eh so eine sache die haben sich jetzt auch direkt aus der hölle
dieses mime check ich ja überhaupt nicht
hat da irgendwie einer den big brain mime durchblick
das kapier ich nicht ist das was in der reality show oder was
das ist ja normalerweise dann die katze da am tisch irgendwie
ein wir starten mit null definitiv
das war im original eine katze ja ja aber ich ich hab keine ahnung wo das herkommt
und ich checks auch nicht
homwell stufe eins dankeschön pock
moment es gibt es gibt es gibt erklärungs mime erklärung mime erklär videos gut warum
nicht natürlich gibt es das was wundert mich das überhaupt dass es so was gibt
keine neue mime aber wusste ich dass die mittlerweile auf youtube gibt
das ist gut habe ich gerade gestern erst gemacht
das ist echt gut sieben times ist der android debug modus schalten wir mit sieben mal tappen
ein
das wirklich nicht schlecht das end stumm
das ist so eine tasse die hätte ich auch gerne
latter ausprobiert
also heute heute nicht ne von der weile schon
big brain schriftung
das ist ja passiert bestimmt nix man kann es einfach weg definieren
aus ist zeh humor
hast du eine ahnung was hast du eine ahnung oder ein tipp wieso mein pc nicht neu startet
oder runterfährt haben ssd system ist auf einer anderen ssd angewandt seitdem ist das
so was mit was schreibst du denn gerade die nachrichten auf twitch
aber die logische antwort ist einfach den pc nicht runter ok dass ich ich gebe zu das
war nicht hilfreich
erstmal überlegen das kann alles sein ja
wieso mein pc nicht neu startet oder runterfährt also wenn der pc nicht nicht runterfährt
ist sehr merkwürdig
wenn der pc nicht startet woher weißt du denn dann dass der nicht runterfährt weil
der ist ja jetzt gar nicht gestartet
ab und zu mal ein bisschen support das nix dagegen einzuwenden
ok wir wollten uns aber eigentlich wollten wir uns nicht proklammer humor angucken sondern
eigentlich wollten wir uns angucken was features wie baldi hat
ja das habe ich oh das ist tatsächlich tatsächlich was war sonst
war das auch vom ccc oder war das habe ich heute gelesen
das habe ich das habe ich gesehen da gab es aber auch letztens einen vortrag drüber
aber habe ich von der zeit schon einen vortrag drüber gesehen
das habe ich letztens gelesen hast du mal link zu das ist vielleicht was sonst wirklich
angucken könnten
das habe ich heute morgen doch gelesen irgendwo muss eigentlich bei heise gelesen sein
hast du eine neue tastatur gefunden ja ich habe mir eine bestellt die g513
hier
denn das das wort könnten wir uns tatsächlich angucken
leider muss man sich die die talks mittlerweile extrem cherrypicken
ich habe ich habe ja grundsätzlich keine probleme mit sozialen politischen orientierten
talks und statements aber mittlerweile ist es halt fast in der unterzahl
muss man wirklich so so umschiffen ja freund freund aufgemacht und das also das wort archiv
aufgemacht auf auf youtube das erste video was mir entgegengesprungen
ist ist irgendwie ein ein gender test oder sowas ist ja alles schön und gut wenn das
interessiert ist ok ich würde mir gerne ein paar technik videos angucken
so was kam denn jetzt heraus hier ich mag kaka ein absolut high iq name
was kam jetzt raus mit dem rechner hat er irgendwas noch geschrieben
da ist was mit ressourcenschutz bei fehlerbehebung dass ein datei schrott
da kann ich da kann ich nicht nichts mit anfangen
hat schon mal versucht mit dem usb stick zu starten
ich muss kamer chat aufholen sonst bin ich wieder so weit hinten
den vortrag können wir uns echt angucken den wollte ich mir nämlich schon angucken
da haben wir doch was das ist bestimmt interessant
der graustreiter macht seine ausbildung im krankenhaus ok
wie gesagt ich war mit meiner mutter letztens im krankenhaus und das erste was mal gemacht
wurde ist in in der notaufnahme aus so einer kiste winos xp gebootet
habe ich mir auch gedacht ah yes hier bin ich richtig
erstmal winos xp buten da verlasse ich meine ich hänge mein leben gerne an winos xp
ja ich wollte schon immer machen und da kann ich wollte das ich wollte immer mal
dass mein leben von winos xp abhängig
ok immer mal media ccc aber auf youtube will ich das ganze haben weil ich will
dumme kommentare von leuten lesen
winos von dem usb stick starten klar kannst du machen
so also wie sind ja hier
war von gestern
patienten
ein bisschen runter scrollen weil das ist gestern gewesen
ah yes
akten nope der ist nicht auf youtube dann gucken wir uns das
anderweitig an
akuma triebohler hat link
excellent excellent
so aber ich muss gerade noch mal kurz was zum chat sagen
hier geht das hier gehts los ok
leute aber vorher müssen wir uns vor kurz wie waldi angucken weil da eigentlich
haben wir wollte ich mir den neuen browser angucken dann gucken wir uns den
vortrag zur gesundheitsakte an
m
hey was hältst du von pihowl
leider
mittler also es ist
ich das projekt finde ich gut
das projekt ist auch sinnvoll und
es lohnt sich ist zu benutzen aber mittlerweile blockt es halt auf den
wichtigen seiten nichts mehr
auf youtube nicht mehr richtig und auf twitch auch nicht mehr richtig
das beste was man aktuell machen kann ist
wenn man ein
kaknup iphone benutzer ist wie ich
m
man holt sich noch
ein android tablet
und installiert sich dann in youtube
eine alternative youtube app
mit adblock drinne
das ist auch der grund warum ich mir noch ein tablet bestellt hab ich hab mir vor ein paar
tagen noch ein fire hd8 bestellt
und hab das ja gestern
so weit vorbereitet dass man das benutzen kann
genau das habe ich trau ab ich auch drauf youtube
wenz
wenz oder wenz wie sich das anhört
oder oder wie spricht man das aus
wenzet
wenz advanced
youtube wenz
ich sammel yugioh karten max sammel tablets
du hast deine yugioh karten aber wahrscheinlich wenigstens in Schutzhüllen
meine tablets nicht
dementsprechend
sehen die auch teilweise aus
achso du hast deine nicht in Schutzhüllen
ich hab auch noch yugioh karten von früher
und ich war auch damals jemand der war immer zu faul das in Schutzhüllen zu machen
du kaufst tablets mit
ios und android ja ich hab
alles mögliche
das meiste sind android geräte
also fast also ich sag mal 70 prozent android 30 prozent ios
ein iphone xr ein iphone
äh was ist denn 6s glaub ich ist das oder ein achter
was ist das moment ich muss gucken
iphone
weiß nicht steht nicht drauf glaub ich glaub ein 6s
ähm
ein ipad
und ein iphone se
und dann halt noch jede menge android tablets
einzige was wir nicht haben hier ist ein android smartphone tatsächlich
benutzt du privat ein iphone
ich benutze das was ich erzählt habe alles privat
also ich benutze
selbst
nur
ios smartphones
allerdings tablets
und auch sonst alles mögliche
ja leider ist es halt unter ios bisschen doof
was äh so die alternativen apps zu youtube und twitch angeht
ach jetzt five fat tribulon nice
man muss sich die frage stellen wie würde vanst ein
jubanto user aussprechen
das sind die wörter haben kaum überschneidung
ein jubanto user würde es wahrscheinlich vanst aussprechen oder
wenz wenzit wenzit würde das jubanto user aussprechen
ja wurde es der akte g513 hab ich
vorhin bestellt
ja das problem bei p-hole ist
dass die eben halt auf twitch und youtube nix mehr bloggen
ok also was hat wie gewaltig für krasse features tab management unique
features give you full control of how your group display tabs
ach es ist tab management
das ist
konnte das von anfang an schon
highly advanced
tabs in tabs
yo dog
i put tab in your tab you can tap while tapping
wie kriegt man das jetzt wieder weg
ok nice brauche ich nicht aber nice
customer tune every part of your browser
oh dark theme
jetzt müssen wir uns gleich angucken wie kommt man in die settings rein
settings was könne hier settings
teams
human das ist das
jubanto
das ubuntu
denn wir machen lieber dark
ach so leute sonnenbrille aufsetzen
nee nee nee nitro express bist du nicht
wir sind jetzt zwar die ganzen krassen linux checker im chat ja
aber trotzdem verwenden viele leute
ich verwende auch privat gerne ubuntu
auch nicht auf dem desktop aber bei mir auf allen möglichen
so lange es kein raspberry pi ist aber auf allen möglichen servos ist
servos auf meiner 4he kiste hier auf meinem nas ubuntu
auf irgendwelchen cloud kisten wenn es nur vm ist ubuntu ich nehme eigentlich für alles ubuntu
auf der arbeit habe ich schon genug red hat
brauche ich das nicht auch noch
user interface ok was haben wir noch für schöne sachen
ok was kann man in den settings alles tolles machen
da kann man aber verdammt viel einstellen das finde ich schon mal echt echt
gut man kann in chrome auch relativ viel einstellen aber doch
es sieht für mich nicht so komplex aus wie hier
oh guck mal man kann sogar das user interface zoomen das
bisschen bisschen fett
user interface
oh hamburgermenü ganz wichtig
display
proxy settings
na gut es ist ziemlich simpel sinken wollen wir nix downloads updates
das ist auch die fault
ach stimmt die haben eine ganz coole gestensteuerung drin gehabt
erinnere mich
dass mir die ganzen sachen custom einschalten das ist schon cool
ok gucken wir uns noch mal die anderen features an user interface
navigation
search options
die frage ist was passiert wenn ich jetzt hier sage ich suche auf google ok
dann macht er ganz normal alles gut
keyboard mouse use custom keyboard shortcuts mouse gestures
a command line controls quick commands
das haben wir eben gesehen
tools notes image
was ist das
ach guck mal da hast du so eine schnelle übersicht
über das was du gerade auf hast
kannst deine tabs durchsuchen die du auf hast weil ich bin ja jemand der hat immer
50 milliarden tabs auf
und du siehst auch die close tabs
das finde ich schön das gefällt mir
take notes
gut notes brauche ich jetzt ok history notes brauche ich jetzt nicht unbedingt
in meinem browser
aber um mal schnell was anzulegen ist es sicherlich nicht verkehrt
downloads und hier hast du bookmarks
also die oberfläche hat sich nicht viel geändert aber die oberfläche war damals schon
cool die oberfläche ist aber deutlich schneller geworden
open guest window
das ist echt
echt nice das gefällt mir
ich sollte das wieder öfters verwenden das ding
so und die standard shortcuts hier funktionieren auch
was wenn man eine tab
gruppe hat kann man die im vivaldi fenster kachen also hat
beide oder mehr seiten nebeneinander offen
ist es jetzt eine frage oder eine aussage
weil ich kann das kann man nicht so ganz folgen irgendwie
es gibt ja gerüchte dass safari von apple jetzt auch auf chrome wechseln
will wie edge
das wäre
wie würde ich das finden
wie würde ich das finden was sind jetzt webkit
safaris webkit oder
also
wie würde ich das finden wenn safari auf auf auf chrome wechselt
prinzipiell
zu sagen wir so 80 prozent fände ich das eigentlich
gerade auf ios
safari und web view
so komplett
hinten dran ist
die fangen da jetzt sachen einzubauen
die andere browser schon ewig haben
eigentlich fände ich es nicht schlecht
aber das liegt eher daran weil apple so nahm war die letzten jahre
gibt doch diese can i use browser
diese seite wo man features nicht angucken kann
hier can i use
so und wenn man da jetzt zum beispiel
nach dem sucht was ich brauche mal gucken ob das in vivaldi geht übrigens
meine kamera meine selbstgestrickte kameraüberwachungssoftware
ob die ob die in vivaldi funs müsste aber eigentlich
fack
ich fand ich fast was geliegt leute
weil ich die kameras nicht umgedreht hat aber zum glück
aber zum glück ist die obere kamera so eingestellt dass man eh nichts sieht
was will denn die vivaldi da jetzt irgendwelche sachen machen
immer fort
aber es funktioniert schon mal das ist gut
ex ist die nein
so wenn man da jetzt zum beispiel nach sagen wir so was wie webrtc sucht
da wird man sehen dass bei ganz vielen sachen wenn man so durchscrollt
na gut jetzt gibt es jetzt zwei sachen das ist jetzt ein blödes beispiel gebe ich zu
aber dass gerade ios safari
bei vielen sachen ein bisschen
ein bisschen hinten dran ist
auf der anderen seite
sind sie bei
codec unterstützungen
besser als chrome unter android
achso
ähm wenn man tabs in tabs hat also übereinander zieht um eine tabgruppe zu
erstellen kann man da rechts liegt drauf war ein tabgruppe krachl auswählen
ok das probieren wir jetzt mal aus
oh
kann das reissens
wenn ich mit tabs in tabs ziehen so
was und jetzt kann man
teiltepp
oh das ist das ist nice das gefällt mir da kann man man kann split view machen
direkt im browser fenster
kann man da jetzt auch sagen ich würde gerne das da reinziehen ne das geht nicht
aber das ist cool man kann in tab
man kann in tab standardmäßig splitted machen
oh das ist richtig cool
das ist richtig cool da könnte ich nämlich zum beispiel
ähm wenn ich was reloade wenn ich irgendwas entwickel frontend mäßiges und was
reloade da könnte ich zwei unterschiedliche seiten drauf ausmachen
aufmachen und reloaden lassen
das ist cool
normalerweise muss ja immer hier mit windows rumhantieren muss immer so
bla bla irgendwie so
aber so ist es viel cooler
das gefällt mir
ein sehr sehr nice feature
wo apple jetzt fällt mir noch was wo safari auch hinten dran ist ist bei
dieser ganzen pwa geschichte
guckt euch an
immer mit service worker braucht
glaube ich das braucht man eh nicht
aber man siehts die anderen browser haben es
safari ist auch übelst hinten dran
generell haben die auf
ios ziemliche probleme was progressive webapps angeht
mit safari weil
safari unterstützt einige dinger
die aber dann in pwas
also quasi pwa ist das das habt ihr wahrscheinlich schon mal gesehen
ähm wenn der browser
euch anbietet das ganze zum start
bildschirm hinzuzufügen
das ist dann quasi in den ein eigenes browser fenster aber halt
quasi den shortcut auf dem auf dem homebildschirm
das kann ios schon ziemlich lange aber die haben den anschluss komplett
verpasst
zum beispiel haben die das problem
das man
im safari selbst
relativ gut audio medios audio ähm
audio video zeugs machen kann
möchte man allerdings audio video zeugs in der pwa machen dann geht das gar
nicht richtig
könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern ich hab doch mal versucht eine pwa zu
basteln im stream
für meine gegensprechanlage
mit dieser china kamera falls ich da noch irgendjemand dran erinnern kann
und diese pwa hat halt ums verrecken
nicht auf ios funktioniert
weil du halt zum sprechen mit einer tür gegensprechanlage logischerweise
mikrofon access braucht
weiß ich nicht ob das mittlerweile geht
aber da ist halt
safari umfauen vor allem die pwa geschichte unter ios ziemlich hinterher
solche sachen
man hat ja eben schon gesehen also
aus diesen gesichtspunkten will ich begrüßen
wenn safari chrome verwendet aber wahrscheinlich
hat das überhaupt keinen einfluss drauf weil safari kann es ja
apple kriegt bloß nicht hin ordentlich im betriebssystem weiter unterstützen
generell gibt es viele sachen unter ios
die mir
echt auf den sack gehen aber trotzdem
wenn ich immer noch hauptsächlich ios ja also unterwegs daheim wie gesagt
gemischmasch aus allen möglichen tablets
was mir unter ios auch richtig auf dem also gewaltig auf dem kicks geht
dass man keine background tasks machen kann das habe ich jetzt schon 20.000
mal im stream erzählt ich weiß
morgen früh gibt es wieder einen sonntag stream ja morgen früh gibt es immer wie
immer
dass man unter ios keine background tasks machen kann das geht mir
richtig krass auf den kicks
ja und dass es auch keine möglichkeit gibt zu sagen ja ich will das machen
wo wir gerade mal genau
wo wir gerade beim thema wie waldi sind genau
ah excellent
klassik
ah yes
hast du schon mal mit unraid hantiert
ich habe mir das ein paar mal angeguckt schon und ich habe das auch mal
irgendwann vor aber da war es schon ganze weile her mal installiert ich sehe
da für mich nicht so richtig den anwendungszweck für
ich glaube so als komplett lösung für leute die technisch nicht so versiert
sind ist das
ganz cool
beziehungsweise die ein was heißt technisch nicht so versiert das stimmt
nicht
leute die
nicht das nicht selber machen wollen einfach was wollen was was tut
und trotzdem daheim die sachen selbst betreiben
wieso kein gelb rakt
ich ich würde die sachen gelb aber selbst da kann man viele sachen nicht
machen
muss man auch dazu sagen
ich würde die sachen gelb raken
problem ist
die dinger gehören nicht mir
die iphone
also das einzige iphone was mir gehört ist da ist das
beziehungsweise gekauft haben ist für meine mutter das iphone se
ähm und das ipad das 6s
und das xr
ist von der firma wo ich arbeite
ich kann nicht die karl
könnte ich wahrscheinlich schon gelb raken aber
ist nicht so beliebt
ok dann hören wir uns mal den vortrag an
zu elektronischen gesundheitstakt den wollte ich eh gucken
bin ich bin ich mal gespannt
was dabei rauskommt
der geht es ab da los
das ist der intro ansager
schreibt der intro intro ansager
und mit einer sache muss ich euch noch
kurz behälligen
hier stehen überall scooter rum und ich weiß es lädt dazu ein bei den wegen die wir haben
wann geht da
guckst du nachher das bahn mining
wenn ich da noch fit bin ja
willkommen zum nächsten talk
hacker hin oder her die elektronische patientenakte kommt
äh unsere drei speaker haben sich beschäftigt mit der sicherheit und
funktionsweise der telematik infrastruktur
ähm das ist so ein bisschen das backend der zukünftigen elektronischen patientenakte
so der weg wie man an die entsprechenden daten rankommt
äh unsere speaker
von mir aus ganz
links
martin
er ist pentester und
also das habe ich schon gelesen der vortrag ist von den drei leuten
zu dem thema auch schon mal als sachverständiger im gesundheitsausschuss hat
da berichtet über das thema
IT-sicherheit in in apps
äh gesundheitsapps
ich kriege immer anfälle wenn die leute so schmatzen beim reden
das ist so nach dem motto
leute ich muss euch jetzt mal sagen
also mein
emote programm was man hier emotes einblenden kann
das äh
eigentlich will ich gar keinen normalen satz machen sondern einfach nur immer
luft holen und dabei
rundherum schmatzen das geht mir voll auf den kegel
dann haben wir
in der mitte
äh andre zierlich
war als sachverständiger im bundesstag
zu genau diesem thema geladen
beziehungsweise dem identifizierung
hast du das in den ältesten videos nicht auch gemacht
ich mach das ich
sag mal so
ich schlucke manchmal wenn ich einen trockenen hals habe das hört sich bei mir
aber nicht so nach jedem so als
an
sondern quasi
ich schluck dann halt
ich mach dann eher so
und schluck halt runter mal
aber es kann sein dass ich den videos auch schon ab und zu gemacht habe
zumindest regert mich das immer das heißt ja nicht wenn man das man wenn man
sowas selbst macht
dass man da unfehlbar ist oder so
christian rudolfsky ihr kennt ihn als ärzt aus dem zirt
tut mir einen gefallen und empfangt die drei mit einem wunderbaren applaus
klapper klapper
ja christian auf gehts
noch frühen stunde
gekommen sind um sich ein talk zu patienten
ist laut genug
anzuhören
nehme ich mal an wissen vielleicht noch gar nicht was die elektronische
patientenakte eigentlich sein soll
die elektronische patientenakte kommt das steht aber fest
einfach um alle auf den selben stand zu bringen gibt es jetzt
kurze einklärung was für die elektronische patientenakte überhaupt
bringen soll
die elektronische patientenakte kurz EPA genannt
ist ein digitales patientenbund EPA
warum
müssen wir alles immer so scheiße abkürzen
EPA
das hört sich nicht an wie elektronische
was heißt eigentlich EPA
elektronische patientenakte genau aber
aber das ist voll un
ungriffig
in dem lebenslang alle gesundheitsdaten gespeichert sind röntgenbilder
arztberechte allergien
ebenso blutwerte medikamente impfungen und vorbehandlungen
alles an einem platz
und für den patienten transparent
denn nicht nur dass er vollen einblick in die EPA hat
er allein besitzt die kontrolle über seine daten
und bestimmt wer zugang dazu haben darf
mit der EPA können mündige patienten freiwillig ihre gesundheitsdaten
spoiler was heißt spoiler ich hab's noch nicht gesehen
aber trotzdem spoiler
es haben nicht nur die drauf zugriff die drauf zugriff haben sollen
sicher online und effektiv verwalten
alle behandlungsrelevanten informationen stehen in jeder
lebenslage zur verfügung
was den austausch mit ihren partnern zur gesundheit ungemein erleichtert
die ganze gesundheit auf einen bleck mit der EPA
ab 1 januar 2021
das wisst ihr was
die hört sich an wie die Rewe wie die Rewe Werbung Sprecherin
ihr
die
Quiz
das ist ein normaler tv spot
egal
volles wurschter
erauto
ist jetzt
genommen. Diese elektronische Patientenakte ist nicht eine weitere App, eine weitere Gesundheitsakte,
wie wir sie auch schon letztes Jahr hier gesehen hatten, sondern es ist die Patientenakte, die
elektronische Patientenakte, die nach Sozialgesetzbuch 5 allen gesetzlich Versicherten
zur Verfügung gestellt werden soll. Sie dürfen diese nutzen, um lebenslänglich ihre Gesundheitsdaten
zu speichern und das ergibt einige Fragestellungen. Zum einen, wir wollen hier drinnen die Möglichkeit
schaffen, lebenslang unsere Gesundheitsdaten zu speichern. Das sind Dinge wie Röntgenbilder,
Arztbriefe, Lebenslang ist halt schon so ein bisschen. All diese Dinge sollen in diese Akte
verwaltet werden können. Und der Patient soll die alleinige Kontrolle darüber besitzen und auch
bestimmen, wer Zugriff darauf hat. Das heißt, das muss sicher sein. Bestimmt, bestimmt. Kann das
funktionieren? Nein. Sorry. Ganz wichtig. Habt ihr es im Hintergrund gehört? Der erste Typ schon. Nein. Kann nicht
funktionieren. Nein. Eigentlich hätte er sagen müssen, ja. Voll übertrieben. Ob das funktionieren
kann oder nicht, wir müssen diese Anforderungen erfüllen. Die Kaufnahme von Verstößen in
Einzelfällen, die ist unzulässig. Das heißt, selbst in Einzelfällen, wir können nicht sagen,
ein Prozent Verlust ist okay, wie das im Fall bei beispielsweise Kontozugängen oder so mal in
Kauf genommen werden könnte, wo man mit monetären Werten handelt. Hier ist es absolut unzulässig,
dass man überhaupt den Einzelfall zulässt, dass es hier zu einem Verstoß kommt. Das sagt ein
Landesdatenschützer, Datenschutzbeauftragter. Und das ist nicht neu, dass hier hohe Anforderungen
stehen, dass auch der Gesundheitsminister, der hat mir noch gefehlt, der sagt, dass der
Datenschutz, besonders die Datensicherheit, die Achillesferse für diese Anwendung ist,
denn wird es hier zu einem Vorfall kommen, wird natürlich die Akzeptanz dieser Anwendung und auch
alle weiteren Anwendungen der digitalen Gesundheitsversorgung wirklich ruiniert. Und
das gefährdet auch dieses Vertrauensverhältnis, Arzt, Patient, in der Sprechstunde natürlich.
Diese ärztliche Schweigepflicht würde, wenn es hier zu einem Vorfall kommt, aufgehoben.
Herr Spahn sagt aber auch, dass er zu dem Thema mehr Geschwindigkeit ranbringen will,
Hacker hin oder her. Und weil das so ein bisschen ambivalent ist, haben wir gedacht,
wir schauen uns das mal an. Das klingt irgendwie widersprüchlich. Und auch die Sicherheit bewerten
zu können, müssen wir 10.000 Seiten Spezifikationen lesen. Die ist alle unter dem Fachportal der
Gematik, die gesellschaftlich dafür zuständig ist, öffentlich verfügbar.
Heißt die wirklich Gematik? Beknackter Name, oder? Die Gema ist irgendwie schon vorbelastet so ein
bisschen. Die Spezifikation der Gematik und dann noch die Spezifikation der Sektororganisation
unseres Gesundheitswesens. Denn unser Gesundheitswesen ist ja ziemlich zersplittert in verschiedenste
einzelne Bereiche. Das haben wir getan, bzw. nicht ganz, aber mal überflogen und haben dann
diese tolle Grafik hier für euch vorbereitet, um euch zu zeigen, wie diese Gesundheitsakte
aussieht, diese Patientenakte. Zunächst einmal der Versicherte mit seiner Gesundheitskarte. Die
kennen die meisten von euch mit dieser Gesundheitskarte und einem Zugangsgerät. Das kann
zukünftig auch ein Smartphone sein. Wenn es NFC-fähige Gesundheitskarten gibt, kann der
Versicherte über das Internet auf ein zentrales Zugangs-Gateway dahinter liegendes Aktensystem
zugreifen. Und auf diesem Aktensystem sollen dann die Gesundheitsdaten liegen, diese lebenslang
verfügbar gehaltenen Gesundheitsdaten. Die sind aber verschlüsselt. Man spricht hier von Ende
zu Ende Verschlüsselung. Wahrscheinlich ist gar nicht mal das Problem, also ich rate jetzt einfach
mal. Wahrscheinlich ist dieses Aktensystem gar nicht mal das eigentliche Problem. Da wirst du
jetzt nicht wirklich irgendwie, es ist nicht so, dass du da irgendwie einbrechen musst oder so.
Wahrscheinlich kannst du, ich vermute das jetzt einfach mal, mal gucken, was dann da rauskommt.
Wahrscheinlich ist der Gateway-Eingang nicht so ganz, war zumindest in der Vergangenheit so,
nicht so ganz sicher, wie man das gerne hätte. Wahrscheinlich könnte ich dann quasi die
Gesundheitsakte hier irgendwie vom Chat abrufen, also Chat. Der Schlüssel zu diesen Daten,
der liegt auch auf diesem Aktensystem. Aber noch nicht lachen, dieser Schlüssel, der ist verschlüsselt.
Moment, Moment, Moment. Was? Der liegt auch auf diesen Daten, die Gesundheitsdaten liegen. Diese
lebenslang verfügbar gehaltenen Gesundheitsdaten. Die sind aber verschlüsselt. Man spricht hier von
Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung. Moment.
Okay, weiter kommt. Der Schlüssel zu diesen Daten, der liegt auch auf diesem Aktensystem.
Ja, warum? Also ich meine, es wäre ja, warum muss der Schlüssel da liegen? Ich meine,
mal angenommen, ich verschlüssel was und schiebe das dann in die Cloud. Dann reicht es doch,
wenn ich den Schlüssel habe, weil wenn ich möchte, wenn ich es jemanden zeigen will,
dann kann ich ja den Schlüssel eingeben quasi oder ich habe irgendwas, was den Schlüssel
repräsentiert oder so. Aber in der Regel uploadest du ja nicht deinen Schlüssel da irgendwie mit.
Okay, gucken wir mal. Aber noch nicht lachen, dieser Schlüssel, der ist verschlüsselt. Der
ist verschlüsselt und das hat auch alles seine Berechtigung. Nur ist jetzt die Frage, wir haben
das Problem nicht gelöst. Wo ist der Schlüssel für den Schlüssel? Genau, genau. Und da müssen wir
ein bisschen weiter gehen. Da müssen wir schauen, dass wir hier rüber. Okay, doch, doch, ich verstehe
es. Ich glaube, ich glaube, das ergibt insofern Sinn, also wenn die das so machen, ergibt es
ergibt insofern Sinn, dass ich quasi ohne, dass ich einen Schlüssel brauche, quasi von anderen
Geräten oder aus der Arztpraxis oder sonst wo quasi drauf zugreifen kann, wenn ich es irgendwie
autorisiere oder wie auch immer. Das werden sie sich so gedacht haben, so nach dem Motto, dass ich
mehrere Endpunkte haben kann, die nicht alle immer den Master Key haben müssen oder so was in der
Richtung. Die haben sich da wahrscheinlich schon was bei gedacht. Ob das so sinnvoll ist, sei mal
dahingestellt. Telematikinfrastruktur angebunden werden. Die Telematikinfrastruktur ist das zentrale
Netzwerk, an das inzwischen schon 115.000 Arztpraxen zukünftig auch Apotheken, Krankenhäuser und andere
Einrichtungen des Gesundheitswesens angeschlossen werden. Also das heißt im Endeffekt, die billige
Variante, wenn mal einer in die Apotheke einbricht um die Ecke, dann hat er Zugriff drauf oder wie ist das?
Das ist ein VPN-Netzwerk mit eigenem Vertrauensraum und dieses Netzwerk hält folgende zwei Dienste
bereit. Den Schlüsselgenerierungsdienst 1 und den Schlüsselgenerierungsdienst 2. Das sind Dienste, die uns
einen Schlüssel generieren und zwar einen berechtigten Schlüssel. Wir müssen also mit unserer
Gesundheitskarte zu den Schlüsselgenerierungsdiensten gehen und uns diese blauen berechtigten Schlüssel
abholen, indem wir uns ausweisen, als für sich hätte. Dann nehmen wir diese blauen berechtigten
Schlüssel. Das wirkt jetzt schon auf mich übertrieben komplex das ganze System. Schlüsseln damit diesen
pinken Aktenschlüssel und dann kommen wir an die Gesundheitsdaten. Für Ärzte, die ja auch auf diese
Akte zugreifen müssen, um Dokumente des Versicherten dort einzustellen, beispielsweise ein Arztbrief oder
ein Untersuchungsergebnis, sieht das von der anderen Seite fast genauso aus, nur dass dort noch ein
spezielles Zugangsgerät verwendet wird. Jede Arztpraxis, die an diese Telematikinfrastruktur
angebunden wird, benötigt einen sogenannten Connector. Das ist ein spezieller VPN-Router mit
weiteren Funktionen. Das habe ich schon gehört. Da hat sich mein Zahnarzt mal drüber aufgeregt,
dass sie das irgendwie haben müssen und da habe ich auch schon mal was drüber gelesen. Dieses
geschützte Netz ermöglicht und während der Versicherte sich mit der Gesundheitskarte ausweist,
um auf diese Schlüsselgenerierungsdienste zugreifen zu können und sich seinen Schlüssel generieren
zu können, greift der Arzt oder die Ärztin mit ihrem Praxisausweis und auch mit Heilberufsausweisen
auf dieses Netz zu bzw. auf Anwendung darauf laufen. Warum greift der Arzt da überhaupt auf meine
Daten zu, ohne dass ich es autorisiert habe? Ich meine, ich verstehe, dass der Arzt, dass ich den
Arzt autorisieren muss, bevor er mich ordentlich behandeln kann. Das leuchtet mir alles ein. Aber
ich meine, ich habe ein Interesse daran, dass der Arzt mich behandeln kann. Also werde ich
den Arzt noch autorisieren? Mit deiner Behandlung autorisierst du. Ja, aber so richtig autorisieren
müsste ich das doch erst, wenn ich dann quasi mein Passwort da eintippe oder quasi in meinen
Authorized Keyfile eintrage sozusagen. Das ist also symmetrisch. Sobald der Patient als auch Ärzte
haben Chipkarten, mit denen sie sich hier ausweisen und Anwendungen gegenüber authentisieren. Max
liegt im Graben. Ja gut, das ist natürlich ein Argument. Das stimmt, wenn ich in der Ecke liege
und den ich autorisieren kann, dann ist es schlecht. Das leuchtet mir ein. Ja okay,
das ergibt Sinn. Um das Risiko dieses Netzwerkes ein bisschen zu vereinfacht darzustellen, schauen
wir uns mal an, wie viele Teile es denn davon gibt. Es gibt 73 Millionen. Aber trotzdem könnte man
auch ohne Probleme machen. Ich könnte es einfach vorher einmalig frei geben, dass ich sag so nach
dem Motto, okay, so opt in quasi, so nach dem Motto ja. Wobei das macht dann keiner, wenn man
es opt in macht. So nach dem Motto ja, Notarzt darf, nee das ist doof, opt in macht keiner.
Dann liegen die Leute echt im Graben. Eher opt out ja, weil opt in ist immer das Problem. Das
machen die Leute nicht. Oder generell immer wenn die Leute was machen müssen, dann machen sie es
nicht. Es gibt in etwa vier Anbieter von dieser Patientenakte, die sich jetzt schon aktuell in
der Entwicklung befindet. Denn in zwölf Monaten soll sie uns allen zur Verfügung stehen. Und es
gibt eine einzige zentrale Telematikinfrastruktur. Und da gibt es halt diese 115.000 Arztpraxen, die
jetzt schon angeschlossen sind, beziehungsweise ganz grob geschätzt so 170.000 Einrichtungen,
die irgendwann mal dort angeschlossen sein sollen. Die Prozesse, wie diese Chipkarten verteilt
werden, das sind auch Prozesse der zentralen Telematikinfrastruktur. Problem bei diesem
Schlüsselgenerierungsdienst ist, der Versicherte oder die Ärztin weisen sich jeweils nur noch aus
mit einer Karte und bekommen dann einen Schlüssel. Ob das die Ärzte sind, die die Karte haben,
ist was anderes. Das hat das Problem, dass wir hier zwar weiterhin von Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselungen
hören, aber der Schlüssel ist nicht mehr unter Kontrolle des Versicherten. Das heißt, wer sich
ausweisen kann, auch mit einem Nachfolgeausweis, der bekommt Zugriff, der bekommt den Schlüssel und
kommt damit an die Daten. Auch das BSI hat dazu schon eine Anmerkung gemacht und hat gesagt,
wenn dieses Authentisierungsverfahren dieses Schlüsselgenerierungsdienstes überwunden wird,
kann auf den gesamten Akteninhalt zugegriffen werden. Die Gematik leitet daraus ab, dass die
Korrektheit dieser rot markierten Kartenherausgabeprozesse, die ich eben mit diesen roten
Pfeilen dargestellt hatte, Grundvoraussetzungen für den sicheren Betrieb dieser Anwendung ist.
Kartenherausgabeprozesse, das bedeutet die Überführung von einer real existierenden Person,
auch einer juristischen Person wie einer Arztpraxis, in die digitale Welt. Um das sicher
gewährleisten zu können, muss Folgendes erfüllt sein. Ich muss Personen identifizieren. Versicherte
Ärzte, Arztpraxen müssen zuverlässig identifiziert werden. Und die Attribute, ob sie nun zugelassener
Arzt... Vor allem das muss ja auch, was ja bei so Authentifizierungs-Sachen immer problematisch
ist, ist ja das revoken von Sachen. Also sprich, wenn ich mal was erlaubt habe, wenn ich mal was
ausgestellt habe, wie krieg ich der Welt wieder mitgeteilt, dass das nicht mehr so ist. Da
bin ich auch mal gespannt drauf, wie sie das machen wollen. Was? Baumi fragt, ich habe
versucht, dein Versandstarker-Lokal auf meinem Debian zum Laufen zu kriegen. Du nutzt ja
Castrol als Webserver. Ich müsste das über Virtual Host dann umleiten. Richtig. Also
meine Anfragen an den Server von 80 auf 5000. Wenn du Port 80 verwenden willst... Nee, musst
du nicht. Du kannst einfach ein Parameter angeben beim Starten, dass er mit Port 80 startet.
Müsste, glaube ich, funktionieren. Du musst mal... Achso, du willst einen Apache davor
haben. Ja, da musst du Reverse Proxy in dazwischen. Ja. Das müsstest du machen. Oder versicherte
mit einer bestimmten... Aber, also, ich finde es super, dass du Software von mir verwenden
möchtest. Aber ich muss sagen, ich habe lange am Versandstarker nichts mehr gemacht. Das
ist halt so in der Schwebe das Ding, das er geht. Aktuell geht er noch. Es könnte durchaus
sein, dass er bald nicht mehr geht. Und ich weiß nicht, wann ich dazu komme, das Ding
endlich mal jemals ordentlich fertig zu machen. Versicherte Nummer sind, die müssen sicher
rechtssicher bestätigt werden. Und der Empfang des Zertifikats und des privaten Schlüssels,
also dieser digitalen Identität, die mir dann zugeordnet wird, also des Ausweises der Karte,
die muss sicher nachvollzogen werden können. Also die bestätigte Schlüsselübergabe. Wenn
das alles low läuft, dann funktioniert das System sicher, weil dann dieser Ausweis wirklich
nur in der Hand des Berechtigten ist. Die Gematik weiß das ebenso und spricht deswegen
sehr häufig von dieser Anforderung der zuverlässigen Identifizierung. Also, man liest das wirklich
häufig. Also was soll ich sagen? Zuverlässige Identifizierung muss gewährleistet sein.
Belastbare Bestätigung der Identität notwendig. Eindeutige Identifikation notwendig. Das ist
im Prinzip eine Grundvoraussetzung, eine zweifelsfreie Identifikation. Ich schreibe immer das gleiche.
Zertifikanznehmer und Antragsteller müssen identifiziert werden. Es geht vor allem darum,
dass Kommunikationspartner eindeutig identifiziert werden. Lass mich raten, es ist nicht so.
Identifizierung muss zuverlässig sein, muss notwendig, zwingend notwendig, Grundvoraussetzung
und und und und. Was für Identitäten gibt es denn? Also, wir haben schon drei Karten gesehen. Es
gibt die Gesundheitskarte, es gibt den Heilberufsausweis, es gibt den Praxisausweis und
dann gibt es noch einen Connector. Das ist diese Hardware-VPN-Route, von dem ich sprach. Und die
alle tragen kryptografische Identitäten in Form. Warum braucht man eigentlich eine Connectorbox
dafür? Weil ich meine, es gibt genug VPN-Services, die gehen einfach und die werden auch von Firmen
verwendet, wo es um Millionen geht im Endeffekt. Also, warum braucht man eine extra Connectorbox?
Warum kann man nicht nochmal etwas etabliertes nehmen, sowas wie IPsec oder OpenVPN oder meinetwegen
was Neues, WireGuard, Manipulationssicherheit? Gut, aber das, was dahinter betrieben wird,
hat die Connectorbox doch keinen Einfluss drauf. Weil ich meine, dass man den Connector nicht
manipulieren kann, ist okay, aber den Windows XP-Rechner vom Arz, den kann man garantiert
manipulieren. Der dann da irgendwie dahinter dran hängt. Zumal, ja er sieht wirklich aus
wie aus den 80ern, zumal ist es immer so eine Sache, bei OpenVPN und IPsec weiß ich wenigstens
was es macht. Wahrscheinlich macht es unter der Haube auch nichts anderes. Ich könnte
mir vorstellen, dass das tatsächlich alles relativ sicher ist, aber die Angriffspunkte
an ganz anderen, viel dünneren, dünneren, also an ganz anderen Punkten die Schwachstellen
zu finden sind. Von Zertifikaten und privaten Schlüsseln, die auf Chipskarten gespeichert
sind. Und was wir gemacht haben ist, wir haben uns angeschaut, ob diese Herausgabe denn sicher
ist. Denn das ist der zentrale Angriffspunkt. Wenn wir die Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung
nur noch durch eine Authentisierung sicher garantieren können, dann greifen wir die
Authentisierung an. Ist das möglich? Ja, danke Martin. Ich wollte ganz kurz einschieben,
wie wir uns eigentlich kennengelernt haben. Als Vertragsarzt hatte man letztes Jahr oder
dieses Jahr das Problem, dass einem diese Telematikinfrastruktur so ein bisschen übergeholfen
wurde. Also mittlerweile bekommt man Honorarabzüge, wenn man sie nicht installiert hat. Echt?
Und da war ich so ein bisschen unglücklich drüber. Hab dann erst den Emily, den Markus
Dränger angeschrieben, angesprochen. Wir erinnern uns BEA, ich sehe da viele Parallelen.
Der hatte aber gerade eine wichtigere Aufgabe und deswegen hat er mich an den Martin Tschirsich
... Ja, er kommt direkt von der Baustelle. Sieht echt so aus. Aber ich meine, warum nicht?
Sprich, hat sagt er nichts über seine Kompetenz aus, ja? Weiter verwiesen und uns zusammengebracht
und wir haben uns dann zusammen diese einzelnen Komponenten mal angeschaut. Ich fange mal
an mit dem Institutionsausweis, auch Praxisausweis oder SMCB-Karte genannt. SMCB? Wenn man sich
den, wenn man so einen haben will, muss man online einen Antrag stellen. Da gibt es mehrere
Anbieter für. Wir haben uns mal für den entschieden. Der hat so ein Formular, das kann man im Web
ausfüllen, übrigens auch über Tor, funktioniert auch und muss da verschiedene Daten eingeben.
Abgeglichen werden insbesondere diese fünf, die ihr hier seht. Die Betriebsstättennummer,
Geburtsdatum des Arztes, die lebenslange Arztnummer, der Name und die Profession. Also was für
ein Arzt das ist. Gynäkologe. Geht das gerade nicht so gut. Hops, da. Zack. Das Geburtsdatum
ist die einzige dieser Angaben, die nicht auf jedem Rezept und jeder Überweisung steht,
die ihr von eurem Arzt bekommt. Na geil, Moment. Und Geburtsdatum. Na toll, na toll. Das heißt,
ich weiß schon mal alles, ich weiß schon mal alles von der EGAR. Die Gemeinschaftspraxis
hat irgendeine Rechtsform, meistens sind die in den Partnerschaftsregister eingeteilt.
Wow. Okay. Die Karte des Versicherten, also ausgelesen werden können. Darauf kann ich
mit der Karte zugreifen und ich kann Nachrichten bald, das ist auch noch nicht freigeschalten,
im Comli, in der sicheren Kommunikation der Leistungserbringer empfangen und absenden
im Namen der Arztpraxis. Sichere Kommunikation der Leistungserbringer, das ist auch so ein
krasser deutscher Satz, oder? Hallo? Wie ich das gemacht habe. Ja, also anfangs werden
da, glaube ich, PDFs hin und her geschickt. PDF fort, glaube ich, ist noch ein anderer
Talk. Wahrscheinlich ist der gesamte Schriftverkehr entweder offline oder es ist ohne unverschlüsselte,
unsignierte Mails. 100 pro. Das würde richtig gut passen. Oder fax. Fax ist es wahrscheinlich.
Wo ist das grundlegende Problem? Einschreiben. Und die verschicken im Prinzip auf die gleiche
Art und Weise diese Karten. Also bei den Anbieter, bei denen wir das geprüft haben, war das problemlos
möglich, sowohl die Anfrage entsprechend zu stellen, als auch die Auslieferung entsprechend
umzuleiten, um an diese Karte zu kommen. Medisign hat allein schon 80.000 Institutionsausweise
stand vor 3 Monaten ungefähr ausgegeben. In den Spezifikationen der Gematik steht drin,
dass möglicherweise kompromittierte Zertifikate zurückgezogen werden müssen. Ja, ja gut,
wenn das kompromittiert ist, dann müssen wir es halt zurückziehen. Aber wir machen
jetzt erstmal weiter. Oh, it's a big brain move. Ist erstmal E-Mail Adressen aus Nigeria
oder so.
Jetzt ist es dazu gekommen, weil die Kassenärztliche Bundesvereinigung, die dafür zuständig ist,
diese Prozesse zu spezifizieren, diesen Prozess eben nicht richtig spezifiziert hat. Der Trust
Service Provider, also in dem Fall Medisign, hat Fehler bei der Umsetzung gemacht und die
Gematik als übergeordnete Behörde hat diesen Prozess und diesen Service Provider so zugelassen
und eben nicht geguckt, was der wirklich macht.
Ok, also das gleiche wie bei irgendwelchen CAs, die auch komische Dinger machen, lass
keinen jucken. Erinnert euch noch an Komodo, den sie das RUT-Zertifikat geklaut haben?
Das war Komodo, ne? Komodo war das. Wo sie das RUT-Zertifikat geklaut haben als CA, wo
sie das dann erst irgendwie nicht verraten wollten und sowas. Machst du Live-Reaction?
Ja, wenn ich... Moment, es ist 21 auf 15? Ist es schon so spät? Dann gucken wir uns
den Bahnbeitrag vielleicht auch noch an. Ja, mal gucken.
Da müssen wir uns aber beeilen, dass wir damit fertig werden.
... Berufsausweis oder Arztausweis.
Ja, 22 Uhr.
Wenn man den beantragen möchte...
Das ist 21 auf 15.
... braucht man eine persönliche Identifikation, bevor dieser Ausweis geliefert wird. Braucht
man? Braucht man nicht.
Haha, wie?
Gibt da das sogenannte Bank-Ident-Verfahren. Erklär ich auch gern kurz. Ein Arzt, eine
Ärztin geht irgendwann zu ihrer Bank. Die Deutsche APO-Bank bietet das an. Die ist auch
gesellschaftlich mit der Gematik verwandelt und öffnet dort ein Konto oder schaut nun
mal so vorbei, zeigt ihren Personalausweis oder Reisepass und hat dann den ersten Teil
dieses Ident-Verfahrens durchlaufen. Eine Angreifer geht wieder zu einer dieser Trust-Service-Provider,
zieht die Daten der Ärztin ein, die Bank sagt, jo, die kennen wir. Die hat bei uns
ein Konto. Und die Ärztekammer sagt, jo, die kennen wir. Die ist bei uns Ärztin für
eine Sthesiologie, was auch immer. Was macht Medi-Sign dann? Stellt einen Arztausweis aus
und schickt ihn zu.
Wollen die nicht vielleicht mal eine Test-Überweisung machen oder irgendwie was? So nach dem Motto
hier ist eine Überweisung mit einer geheimen Nummer drin, die muss die bei uns eintippen
oder sowas. Das macht jeden 0815 Online-Bank, Paypal und alle möglichen. Aber das ist zu
Big Brain dafür wahrscheinlich.
Tja, und schon hat er den Ärztenausweis. Toll.
Auch hier wieder Lieferung an Lieferadresse, alles bequem, kein Problem. Der PIN wird netterweise
auch gleich dahin geschickt. Und so konnten wir den Heilberufsausweis dann auch online
freischalten. Da gibt es so ein kleines Tool, das man sich runterladen muss von der Homepage
und dann hat man so ein gültiges Benutzerzertifikat.
Muss ich auch sagen, die sieht richtig Big Brain aktuell aus, die Webseite.
Dafür ist eine Unterschrift notwendig. Ich habe eben schon davon gesprochen, wo wir die
Nummern her hatten, die Arztunterschrift ist da auch meistens drunter, wenn man sie überhaupt
lesen kann. In vielen Fällen ist es auch so, z.B. bei der Postabholung, dass die Originalarztunterschrift
auch nirgendswo hinterlegt ist, d.h. es ist halt einfach kakel drunter und meine Unterschrift
kann man wirklich nicht lesen.
Aber schön, dass du mal ein Insider wirst hier, die du im Westen gibst.
Das ist relativ sehr leicht zu imitieren. Auch hier wieder, wo ist das Problem?
Das wundert mich aber nicht.
Es gibt zwei Anbieter, gibt insgesamt vier Verifikationsverfahren, Postident und Kammerident
sind nach den Verifikationen so in Ordnung. Die beiden Verfahren, in denen eine zweizeitige
Identifikation stattfindet, klappen nicht so gut.
Das ist einmal das Bankident-Verfahren und zum anderen das Vorabkammerident-Verfahren,
bei dem auch eine zweizeitige Identifikation stattfindet.
Oh Gott, ist das scheiß kompliziert. Das kann nicht richtig funktionieren.
Das ist so krass kompliziert, das kann nicht mehr funktionieren.
Also, wie soll das, was machen? Was? T-System ist nicht mehr drinnen?
Stattfindet, d.h. der Arzt geht irgendwo hin, zeigt seinen Ausweis und irgendwann später
kommt jemand online und sagt, hallo, ich bin dieser Arzt oder diese Ärztin. Es gibt keine
Möglichkeit, diese beiden Identitäten zusammenzuführen und abzugleichen, ob derjenige, der sich online
einklickt, wirklich derjenige ist, der seinen Ausweis hochgehalten hat.
Das sind beim Medisign 31% der Heilberufsausweise, weil es eben so ein bequemes Verfahren ist.
Bei den anderen Providern wissen wir nicht, wie viele Ausweise über dieses Verfahren
ausgestellt wurden.
Und damit zu unserem Spezialisten für die elektronische Gesundheitskarte.
Damit hatten wir jetzt also gezeigt, wie man auf diese zwei Karten sehr einfach zugreifen
kann. Also, wie man sich erschleichen kann, diese Karten auf einen oder anderen Namen.
Aber es fehlte die Gesundheitskarte in diesem Quartett an Identitäten. Ich glaube, ich
hatte damals bei Google eingegeben, irgendwie Gesundheitskarte erschleichen oder so.
So einfach mal, was man so bei Google sucht.
Dann haben wir auf den Experten für Erschleichen von Gesundheitskarten gestoßen, der André
Zilch. Und der wird euch jetzt mal erzählen, wie das geht.
Danke. Die Gesundheitskarte ist genau das Äquivalent zu dem Institutionsausweis und
zu dem Heilberufsausweis für die Versicherten. Viele von ihnen werden es kennen und es ist
der zentrale Zugangsschlüssel für die Versicherten in diese Telematikinfrastruktur. Eine Frage,
die in den vergangenen Jahren immer wieder diskutiert wurde, ist, ist denn die Gesundheitskarte
Identitätsnachweis? Ist es kein Identitätsnachweis?
Tomtricks, weißt du, was diese Connectorbox macht? Also, ist das ein OpenVPN? Ist das
ein IPSEC? Ist das was eingestricktes oder was ist das? Oder ist das geheim? Ist das
quasi, so nach dem Motto, erst mal alles geschwärzt, bevor man da was drüber erfährt?
Mich mal interessieren, was das ist. Ich meine, es wäre ja gut, wenn man irgendwas verwendet,
was etabliert ist. Ich erinnere nur mal da dran, die Telekom hat damals ja, wo es um
den neuen Encryption-Standard geht, da wo AES gewonnen hat, haben die ja auch einen Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus
eingereicht, stopp hieß auch Magenta oder so. Und da ist ja in der ersten Runde schon
herausgeflogen, so viel zur Sicherheit und Telekom und so. Das ist geheim. Okay, wenn
Verschlüsselung und Security-Sachen geheim sind, ist meistens schon mal ein schlechtes
Zeichen, oder? Das ist top secret. Stätigt sie rechtlich die Identität oder ist das einfach
nur so was wie eine Kundenkarte? Und welche Auswirkungen hat es denn, wenn es kein Identitätsnachweis
wäre? Spielt das eine Rolle? Jeder Arzt kennt seinen Versicherten, ist das tatsächlich
so oder hat es eine andere Funktion? Vor der elektronischen Gesundheitskarte gab es die
sogenannte Krankenversichertenkarte. Die hatte allein die Aufgabe, zu Abrechnungszwecken zu
verdienen. Die haben übelst gescampt damals mit der Versicherungskarte. Meine Mutter hat
ja in der Kinderarztpraxis gearbeitet und da haben regelmäßig Leute versucht mit gescherrten
Krankenkassenkarten mit ihren Kindern hinzugehen. Und das ist die Frage, ob sie das bei allen
gemerkt haben, eher nicht. Also da wurde auch schon heftig versucht zu scammen immer. Ärzte
gegenüber den Kassen letztendlich, die ihre Rechnungen stellen und so wurden sie bezahlt.
Bei der Gesundheitskarte ist es als äquivalent zu Heilberufe ausweisen oder auch zur Institutionkarte
und ist der zentrale Zugangsschlüssel für die Versicherten ins Gesundheitswesen. Im Rahmen
der Digitalisierung werden immer mehr Leistungen im Gesundheitswesen arbeitsteilig erbracht
und immer mehr digitalisiert. Im Rahmen der Einführung der elektronischen Gesundheitskarte
gab es auch die sogenannten Paragraph 291a SGB V Anwendung. Ach der Paragraph. Medizinische
Anwendung, was soll mit der Gesundheitskarte noch alles gemacht werden. Es soll so weit
gehen, dass sogar der Ort gespeichert wird, wo der Patient die Zustimmung zu seiner Organspende
abgelegt hat. Also nicht die Zustimmung selbst, sondern allein wo ist der Ort. Und natürlich,
wir haben es vorhin schon gehört, der zentrale Zugangsschlüssel für die elektronische Patientin.
Darüber hinaus bleiben und kommen Anwendungen hinzu, wie zum Beispiel bei Direktkrankenkassen,
die gar keine Geschäftsstellen mehr haben. Die müssen ja irgendwie elektronisch mit
ihren Versicherten kommunizieren. Die Anforderungen, wir hatten es vorhin gehört, selbst in Einzelfällen
darf es nicht möglich sein auf die Gesundheitsdaten zuzugreifen. Aber es gibt solche Instrumente
wie eine Patientenquittung. Und in dieser Patientenquittung steht drin, was die Krankenkassen
für die einzelnen Versicherten in den vergangenen 18 Monaten gezahlt haben.
Oh Tomriks, das klingt schlüssig. Hier kommen wir auf das zurück, was Martin
Anfang sagte. Die Identität des Verfahrensbetroffenen muss vor Übermittlung von Sozialdaten festgestellt
werden. Das ist ein ganz zentraler Punkt und der sich ganz wesentlich davon unterscheidet,
was wir aus anderen Bereichen kennen. In anderen Bereichen kann es ausreichend sein, dass man
eben nachhinein feststellt, ach du liebe Zeit, da ist ja etwas schief gelaufen.
Ja gut, aber da willst du ja nicht, dass die Falschen kriegen, oder was? Du willst nicht,
die dürfen nicht die Falschen kriegen. Hier bei der Übermittlung von Sozialdaten,
von Gesundheitsdaten wird Wissen übermittelt. Es geht Wissen aus den Krankenkassen raus,
was haben die Patienten, welche Leistungen wurden erbracht? Und dieses Wissen ist nicht
zurückzunehmen. Wenn es einmal draußen ist und in den Händen der falschen Person gelangt
ist, ist es weg. Deswegen sind so klassische Verfahren und Drohpotenziale, ich kann hinterher
feststellen, wem irgendwelche Informationen zugegangen sind, hier nicht hilfreich. Als
verschärfende Maßnahme kommt oder verschärfendes Element kommt hinzu, dass eben in Einzelfällen
schon verhindert werden muss, dass man auf diese Daten zugreift und deswegen sagen die
Datenschützer, es müssen Verfahrenswege vorgegeben werden, die gar nicht erst die Gefahr bergen,
gegen das Sozialgeheimnis zu verstoßen. Das heißt, diese Verfahren müssen wirklich wasserdicht
sein, sodass man von vornherein ausschließen kann, dass diese Informationen an die…
Das Problem dabei ist doch, wenn er jetzt sagt, diese Verfahren müssen wasserdicht
sein, gebe ich ihm recht, vollkommen klar, aber umso komplizierter du das machst, umso
weniger wasserdicht ist irgendwas und vor allem umso komplizierter du was machst, umso
schlechter ist es überhaupt nachzuvollziehen und vielleicht sogar zu beweisen, dass es
wasserdicht ist. Das funktioniert doch überhaupt nicht. Unberechtigten ausgegeben werden, weil
das so ein zentrales Element ist, wurde schon sehr früh bei der Einführung der Gesundheitskarte
bzw. das war noch vorher, nämlich bei der Definition der Sicherheitsarchitektur bereits
im Jahr 2003 und 2004 festgelegt, dass einerseits der Schutzbedarf sehr hoch ist. In der Zeit
haben wir fast den Flughafen fertiggebaut. Und es wurde auch bestimmt, dass Identitäten,
die als Basis für elektronische Zertifikate dienen, genau auf demselben Schutzbedarfsniveau
erfasst und bestätigt werden müssen, wie diese Zertifikate. Das macht ja Sinn, weil
das schwächste Glied bestimmt die Kette. Daraufhin wurde festgelegt, dass die Verfahren,
wie Krankenkassen die alten Krankenversichertenkarten ausgegeben haben, dass das nicht mehr ausreichend
ist, nämlich damals wurden einfach diese Versichertenkarten auf Zuruf, meine Karte ist defekt, ich habe
verloren, ich habe meine Krankenkasse gewechselt, wurden diese Karten neu ausgegeben. Und hier
wurde bestimmt, dass die Fachverfahren zwischen den Versicherten und der Krankenkasse auf
das neue Niveau anzupassen sind und es wurden explizit die Worte Identifizierung und Registrierung
genutzt. Bei den ganzen Aufwendungen, die man im Rahmen der letzten Jahre durchgeführt
hat, hat man einen sehr starken Fokus auf die technische Realisierbarkeit gelegt. Die
organisatorischen Prozesse und Abläufe sind dort leider an manchen Stellen nicht so umgesetzt
worden, wie es vorgegeben war. Im Jahr 2016 hat die CDU-Bundestagsfraktion einen Kongress
durchgeführt zum Thema E-Health. E-Health nennt sich das. Und in seinem Beitrag zu diesem
Thema hat Herr Kauder damals gesagt, es reicht ein einziger Vorgang, um das Vertrauen der
Menschen in dieses digitale Gesundheitswesen. Das Problem ist, dass da immer so viel geschwätzt
wird, wenn der Tag lang ist. Und auch wenn irgendwas passiert, dann sind immer alle erschüttert
und verurteilen das und sonst was. Aber dass man konkret einer sagt, wir planen das und
das zu unternehmen, das gibt es nicht. Das ist erheblich zu erschüttern. Und weiter hat
er ausgeführt, davon wird der Erfolg abhängen, dieser Digitalisierung im Gesundheitswesen,
bis die Sicherheit gelingt. Die ganzen Vorteile sind nett und schön. Aber wenn die Sicherheit
nicht gelingt, dann wird es keine Akzeptanz in der Bevölkerung finden. Wir haben uns
das Ganze mal etwas genauer angeguckt. Martin sagte, das Thema elektronische Gesundheitskarten
begleitet mich selbst schon einige Jahre. Hier sieht man, wann, in welchem Jahr es mir gelungen
ist, mit einfachsten organisatorischen Anläufen jeweils im Besitz eine Gesundheitskarte zu
gelangen. 2014, 2015, 2016, 2017 und dieses Jahr wieder. Die Angriffsszenarien, die wir
durchgeführt haben, unterscheiden sich nur unwesentlich gegenüber dem, wie es anfangs
war. Reicht es anfangs aus, dass ich irgendwo bei einer Krankenkasse angerufen habe und
sagte, ich bin umgezogen und wurde mir eine neue Karte zugeschickt. Das hat sich über
einige Jahre durchgezogen. Nun ist es etwas komplizierter geworden. Wir müssen eine E-Mail
schreiben. Für die meisten Leute ist es eine unüberwindbare Hürde. Und wesentlich um
eine unüberwindbare Hürde zu gelangen, ist es, dass wir die Adresse ändern. Es gibt
zwei wesentliche Angriffsszenarien, die aus unserer Sicht möglich sind, nämlich einerseits
die Adressänderung durch einen Versicherten und die Adressänderung durch Arbeitgeber.
Es gibt ein Meldeverfahren, bei dem Arbeitgeber Informationen über ihre Arbeitnehmer an die
Sozialversicherungsträger senden. In einer Richtlinie, die veröffentlicht wurde Anfang
des Jahres, wurde beschrieben, dass Daten, die über den Arbeitgeber an die Sozialversicherungsträger
gesendet werden, als wahr angenommen werden. Hinzu, man muss ja einfach an der Stelle berücksichtigen,
was sich die entsprechenden Richtlinien vom BSI ansieht, wird formuliert, dass identitätsbestätigende
Ställe besondere Sicherheitsmaßnahmen durchzuführen haben. Sie müssen geschult sein,
müssen ein Sicherheitskonzept haben und das, unterstellt man, wird vom Arbeitgeber automatisch
durchgeführt. Wir haben darauf verzichtet, diesen Angriff durchzuführen. Wir haben uns
erst mal wieder auf die Adressänderung durch den Versicherten fokussiert. Wir haben uns
mal angeguckt, wie macht es denn die AOK Hessen? Und wie Sie sehen, wir müssen eine E-Mail
schreiben und es heißt, aus Datenschutzgründen. Moment, was? Per eingescannten Brief mit
Unterschrift in einer E-Mail als Dateianhang. Naja, gut, das macht doch eigentlich überhaupt
keinen Unterschied. Ich kann es einfach ausdrucken und neu einscannen oder verstehe ich es jetzt
falsch? Persönlich zu ermitteln, entweder in einem Brief oder Fax oder per eingescannten
Brief in eine E-Mail. Aber eine einfache E-Mail reicht nicht. Der Sicherheitsgewinn eines
eingescannten Briefs per E-Mail zu verschicken ist gering, ist Null. Und es ist nicht alleine
damit getan, dass ich dann einfach eine Adresse ändere. Nein, ich kann auch noch direkt online
der Einfachheit halber trotz bestehenden versicherten Stammdatenabgleich, über den auch eine Adressänderung
möglich wäre, kann ich mir gleich eine neue Adresse ändern, eine neue Gesundheitskarte
bestellen. Das heißt, hier haben wir eine ganz einfache Möglichkeit, ein E-Mail zu
schicken mit einem völlig unverbindlichen Schreiben und dann wenige Tage später kommt
an eine neue Adresse. Klar haben wir ein Muster auf der Seite, das war das PDF zum Runterladen.
Und diese Gesundheitskarte, wie ich vorhin sagte, ist der zentrale Zugangspunkt für
die gesamte Telematik-Infrastruktur. Das heißt, einer der Schwachpunkte ist, die nicht...
Also ich beantrage da mal für den Chat jetzt eine Gesundheitskarte. Also Chat, wundert
euch nicht, wenn im nächsten Jahr Leute bei euch ankommen und wissen, dass ihr Sachen
habt. Sicherheitsrelevante oder nicht entsprechende Sicherheitsanforderungen durchgeführte Adressänderungen
durch den Versicherten selbst. Was dazu noch zu sagen ist, wir haben ja die Aussagen des
Bundesministeriums für Gesundheit, dass diese Telematik-Infrastruktur insbesondere deswegen
jetzt unbedingt eingeführt werden muss, weil das Fax ja so unsicher ist. Zumindest
sicherer ist als das Fax. Und damit hat man auch schon eine Pressemitteilung rausgegeben
und die Ärzteblätter haben geschrieben, Telematik-Infrastruktur, diese neue Gesundheitsanzeige ist sicherer
als das Fax. Okay, wenn man das unbedingt will, gut, kann man sagen. Das Lustige ist, wir
haben auch bei Christians Beantragung die Sachen immer schön per Fax abgeschickt. Genau
so hier. Bei welcher Krankenkasse ist da der Chat? Bei der staatlichen Kekistani Einheitskrankenkasse.
Jetzt haben wir eine Aussage, eine AOK, es ist nicht die AOK Hessen, es ist die AOK Rheinland-Pfalz,
die gesagt hat, im Sinne kundorientierter Prozesse müssen Krankenkassen im Rahmen einer
vertrauensvollen Kundbeziehung Postadressen grundsätzlich als wahr annehmen. Okay, kann
man machen. Die Gesundheitsministerin aus Rheinland-Pfalz sagte das bevor. Also ist es
wahr? Ja, weiß ich nicht, es ist grundsätzlich wahr. Nun auf medizinische Daten zugegriffen
wird, ein unbedingt eine Identitätsprüfung stattfinden muss. Ja, G513, genau. Ne, mit
Linearswitches. Wir wissen, dass nächstes Jahr Zugriff auf elektronisch Patientenakte
stattfinden soll. Nicht einer von ihnen hat eine Identitätsprüfung für seine Krankenkasse
durchgeführt. Diese Anfrage hat das ZDF an die Gesundheitsministerin gestellt und es
kam, die Antwort war, das wussten die allerdings auch schon vorher. Und diese Aussage war nicht
von diesem Jahr, sondern die ist von 2015. Ja, weiß. Geändert hat sich bis jetzt wenig.
Darf ich gehen? Okay. Will er eben das abnehmen oder was? Gib den Präsent her. Wir haben
so viele. Also zum Thema Gesundheitskarten und Identitätsnachweis noch eins, es wurde
gesagt, dass die Identitätsnachweis und die Gesundheitskarte ein eingeschränkter Identitätsnachweis
ist. Was ist das? Vornahme zu 60 Prozent. Einen eingeschränkten Identitätsnachweis
gibt es nicht. Es gibt entweder nur bestätigt oder nicht und auch ein PIN ändert an dieser
Aussage der Identitätsbestätigung nichts. Und damit die Gesundheitskarte eingesetzt
werden kann, muss das Ganze mit einem ordnungsgemäßen Identitätsnachweis verknüpft sein. Wenn diese...
Sorry, ich muss kurz vorgehen. Wir haben nämlich so viele Dinge zu zeigen. Sorry. Alles
gut. Bisschen holprig das Ganze, oder? Ja. Ich würde sagen, wir gehen jetzt zum letzten
Teil, zum vierten Teil, zum Kollektor. Also den Vortrag hätte man bisschen schöner machen
können, muss ich sagen. Inhaltlich ist das erst rein, kann man nichts sagen. Bisschen
holprig. Was wir heute eigentlich gelernt haben. Ja, jetzt könnte man uns vorwerfen,
wir hätten ja nur einen Teil der TI uns besorgt und uns angeschaut. Das Herzstück. Ja, genau.
C2HO. Vom Inhalter ist das gut. Es ist auch nicht holprig, die tragen das alle gut vor.
Aber es ist so, es wird immer, es wird quasi erzählt, erzählt, erzählt und dann fehlt
noch so der Bogen nach dem Motto, wo man dann sagt, ah, so ist es. So wisst ihr, ich kann
euch auch eine halbe Stunde irgendwelche Fakten erzählen und dann kann ich sagen, so, so sieht
es aus, jetzt wisst ihr Bescheid. Aber richtig cool sind ja eigentlich, dass da nur, wenn
ich eine halbe Stunde Fakten erzählt habe und am Ende das so zusammenführe, dass man
sagt, ah, ah, yes, big brain. Man kann sich einfach so einen Connector bestellen, so Eats
oder sowas. Ruf ich alles nach, gib Connector. 2500 Euro, habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Oder wie viel hat er gesagt? 2500 Euro für so eine Box. Das muss aber absolut Hightechs
sein, ne? 200.000, nee, nicht 200.000. 200.000 wäre übertrieben. Ich glaube, das hat sich
nur so angehört. Ja, das hört sich an. Das hört sich an, 200.000, aber ich glaube,
er hat gesagt 2500. Das hört sich an wie 2500, aber er sagt 2500. 200.000 wäre absolut
idiotisch. Wollte ich als Hobby-IT-Sack-Mensch jetzt doch nicht investieren, aber wir haben
dann einen Anbieter gefunden, der das Ganze auch den Connector einzeln verkauft. Das war
ein relativ einfaches Prozedere, ein einseitiges Fax an die Firma. Dann hat es ein wenig gedauert.
Also, seriously, liebe beiden Firmen, drei Monate Lieferzeit, das geht nur einen Stern
und deswegen haben wir euch auch die Disclosure-Frist ein wenig gekürzt. Drei Monate Lieferzeit.
Dann wurde dieser Connector mit der... Was machen die da? Wird das erstmal aus dem Stein
gemeißelt, aus dem vollen Block gefräst und dann mit das Silizium von Hand aufgeätzt.
Sicherer TNT-Express-Lieferkette geliefert an eine vertrauenswürdige Person natürlich
wie immer. Ja, damit hatten wir sie alle. Das Quartett, auf dem die Sicherheit dieser
telematischen Infrastruktur beruht. Die zentrale Sicherheitsfunktion oder Sicherheit dieser
telematischen Infrastruktur beruht auf Sicherheit dieser Kartenherausgabenprozesse. Wir haben
gesehen, die sind alle etwas verbesserungsbedürftig. Wir konnten uns ohne Probleme all diese Dinge
verschaffen auf Identität anderer Menschen, anderer Ärzte. Was bedeutet das? Naja, zum
ersten Mal bedeutet das, dass diese großen Hoffnungen bzw. Versprechungen, die gemacht
worden sind, dass die wohl nicht viel wert sind bzw. dass die nicht ehrlich waren. Versprechungen
wie der Gematik, dass wir europaweit ein einzigartiges Sicherheitsniveau hätten. Ja, ja, bla bla
bla bla. Oder auch das Bundesverband der Vertragspsychologen, die sagen, der KS Computer Club, dem ist es
ja auch nicht gelungen, da einzubringen. Deswegen ist es sicher. Ich frage mich auch, woher
die so ein Statement nehmen. Also sowas sollte niemand in die Welt setzen. Das ist ganz gefährlich.
Das stimmt. Das ist ziemlich blöd, das reinzuschreiben. Ihr erinnert euch noch daran, das ist jetzt
ein bisschen ein anderes Beispiel, als die PS3 kein Lilux mehr ausführen konnte. Auf
einmal. Es hat einen Monat gedauert, da konnte wieder Lilux ausführen. Allerdings noch ein
bisschen mehr. Also sowas ist immer gefährlich reinzuschreiben. Das bringt Leute auf Ideen,
die vorher überhaupt keinen Bock hatten, da was zu machen.
Das Bundesministerium für Gesundheit ist natürlich absolut von der Sicherheit überzeugt. Aber
wir wissen ja, absoluter Sicherheit gibt es nicht. Und deswegen, das sagen auch andere,
muss man doch, wenn man hier etwas kommuniziert, was Nutzen hat, aber auch die Risiken bitte
betonen. Und nicht nur von absolutem Reden, sondern sagen, gut, es kann etwas passieren.
Wir haben das Risiko eingeschätzt, wir haben es mal quantifiziert und wenn etwas passiert,
dann sind wir vorbereitet. Wir können diese Riesen mitigieren, wir können dann den Schaden
ausgleichen. Etwas der Art, also wie der Versicherte oder der Nutzer, der Patient hier geschützt
werden kann. Das fehlt völlig bei dieser absolut beherrschten Diskussion von, wir sind ja absolut
sicher, wir sind Weltspitze. Das System, weltweit sagen die Hersteller dann einzigartige Sicherheit.
Wir haben ja gesehen, soweit, ich glaube vielleicht in Leipzig vielleicht Spitze oder so. Also
das Spannende ist auch, dass diese Fehler, die wir hier gesehen haben, die sind nicht
neu. Die Bundesdruckerei weiß schon sehr lange, das veröffentlicht in ihrem eigenen,
in einem eigenen Expertise, wo sie ihre eigenen Produkte wieder anbieten wollen, dass es mit
der T-Dematikinfrastruktur ja gar nicht so sicher ist. Die Bundesdruckerei sagt, dass
diese postalischen Ausgabewege, dieses Verschicken von irgendwelchen hochsicheren Karten, dass
das ja gar nicht so gut ist mit der deutschen Post, die Sachen einfach. Die sind ein bisschen
aufgeregt, wenn sie auf der Bühne stehen. Ich sage also, dass der Vortrag nicht so astrein
ist und sage ich nichts. Ich finde den Vortrag ein bisschen konfus gemacht. Inhaltlich kannst
du nichts so sagen. Die wissen, wovon sie reden. Durch die Luft zu schicken, einfach
ein Nachsenderauftrag reicht und schon habe ich die Dinge bei mir in meiner Adresse. Und
das weiß die Bundesdruckerei. Und die gibt trotzdem diese Karten heraus. Also da muss
man sich fragen, wenn das Wissen da ist, wo ist die Verantwortung? Und dann wissen wir,
dass es nicht nur die Patientenakte ist oder die jetzt spezifizierten Dienste, die nach
Sozialgesetzbuch kommen sollen, die wir alle eben gehört haben. Ganz viele zusätzlich
private Anbieter wollen irgendwann diese Telematikinfrastruktur nutzen, um darüber mit ihren Heilberuflern
zu sprechen, um darüber die Versicherten, mit denen sie sprechen wollen, diese zu identifizieren.
Das funktioniert ja auch alles nicht, wenn wir diese Basisinfrastruktur schon so kaputt
vorfinden. Die Idee ist ja gut. Aber da müssen wir sie auch richtig machen. Und da kommen
wir zu den positiven Aspekten. Denn bevor wir zu dem Gesamtfazit kommen, sollen wir sagen,
es gibt ja auch positive Aspekte. Und dann möchte ich dem André Zierch nochmals Wort
geben. Also wir sehen, dass die wesentlichen gesetzlichen Rahmenbedingungen so geschaffen
wurden, dass auch eine Digitalisierung stattfinden kann. Und die Gematik hat ganz viel richtig
spezifiziert. Und wir finden es auch richtig, dass die Infrastruktur durch staatliche Stellen
kontrolliert wird und dass Anbieter, private Anbieter diese Infrastruktur nutzen sollen,
um weitere Dienste anzubieten. Denn ohne diese Infrastruktur stehen die privaten Anbieter
alle vor derselben Frage, die durch kleine Unternehmen einfach nicht zu leisten sind.
Wie schaffe ich es, real existierende Personen sicher, zuverlässig, rechtsverbindlich in
die digitale Welt reinzubekommen? Das ist einmal auffällig. Gibt es nicht für Identifizierung
seit langem schon sowas? Guck mal, ich habe mir letztens Aldi Talk, Aldi Talk SIM-Karte,
gekauft. Da musste ich als das neue, ich will nicht sagen, dass das die ultimative, ultimative
beste Identifizierungssystem ist überhaupt. Aber die kriegen das ja auch hin. Da musste
ich das Telefon nehmen, eine App installieren drauf. Dann musste ich mir einen Aldi-Account
anlegen und dann hat sie, dann habe ich irgendwie, dann hat diese App irgendeine, ich vermute
mal polnische Hausfrau angerufen, die deutsch gesprochen hat. So sah es da aus und so hat
sie sich angehört. Und der musste sich dann mal einen Ausweis zeigen oder Post-Ident meinetwegen
auch. Und erst danach, und die hat sich das ganz genau alles angeguckt. Und das ist ja
eigentlich kein großes Ding. Das könnte man beim Verschicken dieser Karten doch auch
machen. Und zum anderen für die Betroffenen oder diejenigen, die mitmachen wollen, immer
lästig. Wer will immer irgendwo hinlaufen? Deswegen ist es richtig, jeder von Ihnen
hat auch nur einen Personalausweis, hoffentlich. Genau dieses zentrale Element einer digitalen
Identität fürs Gesundheitswesen zu haben und diese für alle Anwendungen zu nutzen,
das ist genau richtig. Und als notwendige Maßnahmen zur Schadensbegrenzung dessen,
was wir jetzt aufgezeigt haben, auch dort hat die Gematik schon einiges richtig gemacht.
Sie hat spezifiziert, dass die Gematik dann schlicht und ergreifend prüfen muss, ob die
Zulassungen für diese Anbieter bestehen bleiben oder ob sie, weil sie als kompromittiert anzusehen
zurückentzogen werden müssen. Das A und O, das denke ich, das haben wir in den vergangenen
Minuten gezeigt, ist, dass die Beantragung, Identifikation und die Ausgabe entsprechend
dem Schutzbedarf von Gesundheits- und Sozialdaten durchgeführt werden. Diese Prozesse müssen
so sein, dass sie sicher sind und eben nicht wie für eine Kundenkarte. Was ich in den
vergangenen Jahren gezeigt habe und immer wieder Thema ist, die Gesundheitskarte ist
ein Identitätsnachweis und muss auch so bezeichnet werden und so ausgegeben werden. Und um das
Ganze zu machen, durchzuführen, ist es nicht nur notwendig, dass man jetzt an irgendeiner
Stellschraube macht, sondern es sind organisatorische Prozesse neu zu definieren. Diese organisatorischen
Prozesse müssen genehmigt implementiert werden und dann kommt leider der Geschwindigkeitsbestimmte
Schritt, dass ganz viele Personen real von diesen Prozessen betroffen sind und persönlich
irgendwo hingehen müssen. Sie können es nicht online machen. Wir haben es gezeigt,
wir können nicht online, sondern das ist einfach ein Geschwindigkeitsbestimmter Schritt.
So oft das Wort Prozesse. Das hört sich so noch BWL an. Und das wird viel Zeit in Anspruch
nehmen. Und was wir im Laufe unserer Diskussionen auch immer wieder festgestellt haben, ist,
dass es eine organisierte Verantwortungslosigkeit gibt. Es gibt sehr viele Teilbereiche, die
für Teilabläufe und technische Lösungen zuständig sind. Es ist sehr schwierig, dem
Vortrag zu folgen, muss ich sagen. Die Gesamtverantwortung von nicht nur einer Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung
im technischen Sinne, sondern auch, dass man eine Ende-zu-Ende-Betrachtung der organisatorischen
Prozesse durchführt. Das ist total wichtig und das ist entscheidend, damit auch die Menschen,
die real existieren und nicht nur irgendein elektronisches Abbild sind, die Telematik-Infrastruktur
vernünftig nutzen können.
Damit sind wir schon fast am Ende. Das ist die zentrale Statement. Eigentlich hätten
wir diesen Talk mit dieser Folie hier heute zeigen können und wäre dann auch fertig gewesen.
Stattdessen haben wir jetzt 55 oder 50 Minuten geredet, aber trotzdem, ich hoffe, es hat
gefallen. Das sind die zentralen Statements. Man braucht, um diese Telematik-Infrastruktur
sicher gestalten zu können, höchste Sicherheits- und Datenschutzanforderungen. Die Anforderungen
sind auch da, die sind allen bekannt. Grundvoraussetzung, das steht in diesen Anforderungen, ist die
zweifelsfreie Identifikation aller Teilnehmer. Das haben wir ja gesehen, weil man sich ja
nur noch ausweisen muss, um auf diese Daten zugreifen zu können. Was haben wir herausgefunden?
Identifikation findet nicht statt. Diese Schlussfolgerung, die ist so banal, dass man sich doch fragen
muss, wie konnte das passieren? Wie konnte man nicht vergessen, diesen wichtigsten Schritt
hier zu implementieren? Wie konnte das nicht auffallen, selbst nach Sicherheits-Audits?
Audits, wer hat das auditiert? Die müsste es auch schon gleich mal direkt auch mal ein
Audit bei den Audit-Leuten machen.
Ursprünglich war mein Ziel, sich die Technik anzuschauen und sich diese Komponenten machen.
Wir haben wahrscheinlich so diese typische Audit-Geschichten gemacht, die ganz gerne
auch mal bei manchen Firmen gemacht werden, so nach dem Motto, ja, bevor wir das veröffentlichen,
schickt mir nochmal das Ergebnis. Ah, nee, Moment. Also Punkt 2 und Punkt 5, das können
wir so nicht schreiben, aber wir bestellen euch nur nochmal, wenn wir da ein ordentliches
Fazit kriegen. Und schon ist es bestaudet von Arsch.
Mit dem Christian zusammen, der ja autorisiert ist, der Arzt ist. Wir haben schon beim Bestellprozess
aufhören müssen, weil da waren wir schon durch. Vielleicht kommen wir ja nächstes
Jahr dann dazu, wenn diese notwendigen Maßnahmen umgesetzt sind, uns dann nochmal tiefer in
diese Eingeweide zu begeben, aber für heute haben wir unser Ziel schon erreicht gehabt.
Und jetzt ist erstmal ganz wichtig, Arbeit angesagt bei den Betroffenen, bei den Beteiligten,
bei den Verantwortlichen, diese hier geforderten Maßnahmen erstmal umzusetzen, bevor wir dann
nochmal neu an diese Patientenakte gehen und uns dann daran wagen, vielleicht mit einer
etwas moderateren Aussage diese Akte einzuführen und auch ein bisschen ehrlichere Eigen-Selbsteinschätzung
zu dem Thema. Das würde ich mir wünschen für das Jahr 2020, sodass wir 2021 dann
trotzdem den Nutzen kommen können für medizinische Anwendungen, aber nicht so eben. Das haben
wir jetzt gesehen, also so darf das nicht laufen. Ich würde sagen, wir haben noch ein bisschen
Zeit für Fragen, dann werden wir jetzt die Fragen angehen.
Okay, bevor wir das weiter gucken, machen wir erst schon mal den Stream auf für Bahnmining,
auf welchem Kanal bzw. welchem Stream, die haben hier 5 Streams oder so, läuft das Ganze
denn? Ah, da. Guck mal, gibt's schon Link hierzu, nice. Da kommt das. Break.
Hoffen wir mal, dass das die richtige ist. Paar Planen. Bahn. Ja. Ja. 22.10 sind wir dran.
Gut, da holen wir uns noch mal kurz ein paar Fragen an von der anderen Geschichte. Gucken,
ob da irgendwie auch ein bisschen was kommt. GG.
Ja, die gibt es. Hier fragt der User Space an den Martin Thürmisch. Kann ich irgendwo
Ärzte finden, die sich nicht an der User Space fragen? Ich glaube, das ist eine Frage,
die tatsächlich lieber ein Arzt selber beantwortet. Vielleicht gebe ich die Frage, die hält deine
Christian weiter. Also ja, es gibt Ärzte, die sich nicht an die TI angeschlossen haben.
Wenn ihr das googelt, es gibt mehrere Initiativen von Ärzten, die sich weigern, sich anschließen
zu lassen und diese Honorar-Abschläge in Kauf nehmen. Also die bezahlen dafür, dass
eure Daten sicher sind. Ich habe die... Das ist schon ein bisschen kacke, das da. Wenn
ich da Geld für gebe....einfach mal, ihr werdet es finden. TI-frei oder ähnliches,
das findet ihr. Ich meine, die behandeln ja nicht weniger, schlechter oder sonst was.
Dankeschön. Die haben wahrscheinlich nur Schiss, wenn sie da keine Honorar-Abschläge machen
würden, dass da keiner mitmacht freiwillig bei dem Crap. Hier, deine Frage bitte. Danke
für den Talk. Meine Frage ist, in dem schönen Video am Anfang hat es ja geheißen, dass
das alles in Kontrolle des Patienten ist. Wie funktioniert das? Kann dann der Arzt einfach
einen beliebigen Schlüssel anfragen von dieser Infrastruktur oder wie gibt der Patient sein
Einverständnis dafür? Der Patient soll sein Einverständnis über die App geben können
oder auch mit seiner Gesundheitskarte beim Arzt direkt. Das ist die einfachste Variante.
Der Patient geht zum Arzt, steckt seine Gesundheitskarte, gibt eine PIN ein, die einige jetzt schon
bekommen, alle anderen dann nächstes Jahr oder zumindest bevor diese Patientenakte da
ist und gibt dem Arzt damit Zugriff auf seine Patientenakte. Leute, ich überlege mir gerade
meine Oma, wer mit der Patientenakte zum Arzt gegangen und musste erstmal eine PIN eingeben.
Das hätte im Leben nicht funktioniert. Die hätte mich jedes Mal mitgenommen. Das hätte
im Leben niemals funktioniert. Für einen gewissen Zeitraum, den darf er sich selber
aussuchen und damit hat der Arzt Zugriff. Der Arzt, für den Arzt wird dann diese Aktenschlüssel
spezifisch für seine berechtigten Schlüssel verschlüsselt, hinterlegt beim Aktenanbieter.
So funktioniert das. Ist das eine PIN oder kann man da ein ordentliches Passwort vergeben
oder gibt es vielleicht sogar die Möglichkeit per Augenscan, Fingerabdruck, keine Ahnung.
Ja genau, Fingerabdruck. Zahlen PIN mit vier Zeichen. Oh Gott ey. Ich meine Zahlen PIN
mit vier Zeichen. Eine PIN mit vier Zeichen ist eigentlich normalerweise ausreichend.
Mir ging es bloß eher darum, dass ich mir generell einfach Wörter besser merken kann.
Technisch. Aufs Technische können wir dann nach dem Talk auch nochmal gerne eingehen.
Das ist alles sehr kompliziert. Es ist eine symmetrische Verschlüsselung und nicht so
handelsüblich. Danke. Migo von Nummer 8, deine Frage.
Yo, danke für eure Arbeit. Nicht so handelsüblich. AES ist nicht genug
oder was? AES ist zu gut. Gesellschaft, gibt es einen Opt-out für Patienten?
Die Patientenakte soll freiwillig sein. Das heißt, es ist ein Opt-in noch beziehungsweise
aktuell. Es gibt aber verschiedene Sachverständigen, Gruppierungen, Expertisen, die fordern, es
muss ein Opt-out werden, weil mit Opt-in wirklich nicht ausreichend Menschen diese Akte nutzen
werden und dann die positiven Effekte für die Versorgung ausbleiben. Und wenn man diese
Akte ja schon mal hat und man die träge Masse gerne mitnehmen will, dann möchte man gerne
zum Opt-out für fahren, wie das auch schon in anderen Ländern passiert ist. Ich meine,
in Österreich ist ein Opt-out, in Australien ist auch ein Opt-out, wobei auch dort, meine
ich, früher mal von einem Opt-in die Rede war. Das heißt, auch hier besteht diese Möglichkeit,
dass es zukünftig einmal eine Gesetzesänderung geben könnte. Kann man sich alles vorstellen
und dass es dann zum Opt-out geht. Ich möchte darauf aufmerksam machen, dass ich weiterhin
dafür plädiere, dass alle für eins als ein Opt-in bleiben. Denn wer diese träge Masse,
all die, die sich nicht die Zeit haben oder die Expertise, sich das anzuschauen hat, wer
diese mitnehmen möchte, indem er auf ein Opt-out geht, der muss auch die Verantwortung dafür
nehmen. Richtig, richtig. Wenn man das so formuliert, ich glaube, dann bleiben wir länger bei Opt-in.
Richtig. Wenn die Leute Opt-in machen müssen, dann kann man zumindest mal sagen, ja, die
Leute, die Opt-in machen, wissen, worauf sie sich einlassen. Umgedreht ist es ja nicht
so. Dankeschön. Mikrofon Nummer 7. Was möchtest du wissen? Ich hoffe, dass ich jetzt nicht
abfüge. Na, iGambleOptIn heißt im Endeffekt, du willst sagen, ich möchte es machen und
dann wirst du erst in das System da eingefügt. Opt-out wäre dann, du musst explizit sagen,
ich will nicht und du bist standardmäßig dabei. Birnenvergleiche, aber ich kenne jetzt
aus dem Gesundheits- und Pflegebereich ein ganz massives Überlastungsproblem, was eben
Dokumentationspflichten, Abrechnungspflichten etc. mit den Krankenkassen, mit dem Nachweis
der Professionalität der Arbeit in Krankenhäusern, in externen Pflege, die und so weiter und
eben. Das ist krass. Das ist total übertrieben. Und ich habe den Verdacht, wenn man da keine
Digitalisierung reinbringt, ist das ein unglaublicher Overhead, der momentan massiv zulastender
Patienten und der Pflegenden geht. Seht ihr irgendeine Chance, dass man da tatsächlich
effiziente digitale Abläufe reinbringt, die wirklich eine Dokumentation beim Patienten,
eine Abrechnung bei der KV etc. irgendwie schnell und zügig machen und nicht irgendwie
den halben Arbeitstag einer Pflegerin, die meinetwegen etwas anderes machen will, mit
Papierkram daneben blockiert. Also ich gebe dir recht, ich arbeite auch in Krankenhäusern,
freiberuflich oder kurzzeitig angestellt. Ich habe da in den letzten 15 Jahren durch Digitalisierung
nicht erlebt, dass dadurch mehr Zeit für Patienten entstanden wäre. Es gibt ein paar
minimale Verbesserungen, z.B. bei Röntgenaufnahmen, die ja früher nur singulär auf einer Folie
waren, dass die jetzt verschickt werden können und kopiert werden können. Die Fortschritte
sind sehr gering. Die Versprechen sind natürlich da. Wenn sie digitalisieren, haben sie mehr
Zeit für Patienten. Dass das in der Praxis aber wirklich so große Effekte bringt, wie
wir versprochen, würde ich eher nicht erwarten und auch noch nicht sehen für die nähere
Zukunft. Unabhängig davon ist die aktuelle Patientenakte eine Versorgungsakte, d.h. für
die Versorgung geplant und hauptsächlich für die Information des Patienten selber.
Ob die tatsächlich diesen revolutionären Effekt jetzt in unsere Versorgung bringt und
diesen Nutzen, das weiß man nicht. Das will ich aber auch nicht bewerten. Ich bin natürlich
nicht zu meinem Zweifel. Neben dem Nutzen, der auch sehr positiv von einigen Seiten herausgestellt
wird, der auch evaluiert und wissenschaftlich begleitet evaluiert werden wird, auch die
andere Vortrag anfängt, gleich wieder da. Dann muss man abwägen können. Wenn man Nutzen
und Risiko kennt, will man das machen. Es gibt einige Anwendungen, z.B. verschlüsselte
Kommunikationen unter Ärzten, damit die sich gegenseitig Arztbriefe schicken können,
die wirklich einfach umzusetzen sind, die auch sehr sicher kommen werden und die auch
einen sehr hohen Nutzen bringen. Ich denke schon, es gibt Anwendungen, die Nutzen bringen.
Nur wir haben ja mehrfach gehört, der Einzelfall genügt, um das Vertrauen in dieses System
zu reduzieren. Da muss man halt sich überlegen, ob das, was man hier gemacht hat, nicht doch
irgendwie besser geht. Auf jeden Fall geht das besser, dass man ganz grundlegende Stritte
beachten muss. Deswegen haben wir unsere Maßnahmen dargelegt, unter denen wir uns dann vorstellen
können, dass man dann ruhig mal anfängt, mit vielleicht Diensten, die nicht so ganz
so kritisch sind wie die Patientenakte, sondern das COMLE-Verfahren, also sowas wie erstmal
im Unterärzten, und dann schaut, ob das funktioniert und dann Schritt für Schritt weitergeht.
Kann ich mir schon vorstellen, so etwas. Dankeschön. Mikrofon 5, bitte. Unterstützt ihr die aktuell
laufende Online-Petition gegen den TI-Zwang? Die Online-Petition gegen den TI-Zwang ist,
soweit ich herzlichen mir durchgelesen, nicht begründet mit den Gründen, die wir hier
aufführen, warum wir aktuell dafür sind, dass man erstmal gewisse notwendige Maßnahmen
umsetzt. Wir sind hier relativ akkustisch rangegangen, was den Nutzen angeht, sondern haben die Risikodimension
beurteilt und bewertet. Und diese Petition gegen den TI-Zwang, wo es ja auch verschiedene
Bünde gibt, die gehen hauptsächlich in die Richtung Haftungsfragen sind ungeklärt und
die Nutzungsfragen wird oft von Gruppen abgelehnt. Und das, würde ich sagen, muss man den Fachgruppen
überlassen. Also zumindest ich. Das muss man dann den Ärzten überlassen, vielleicht
der Christian hat so eine Aussage. Ich glaube, wir gehen zur nächsten Frage. Mikrofon 4,
deine Frage. Ja, ich wüsste gerne, ob ihr wisst, ob es in der Spezifikation irgendwas
zum Umgang mit der PIN gibt. Also ich habe das in der Arztpraxis erlebt, dass dann ein
Leistungsunternehmen kommt, den Konnektor installiert und zwecks einfacher Fernwartung den PIN
auf eine triviale Kombination ändert bei allen gleich und das in ein Textdokument auf USB-Stick
rausträgt. Ist das erlaubt nach der Spezifikation? Die Leute machen es sich immer einfach. Martin
ist sehrjenigen von uns, die die Spezifikation auswendig kann. Aber ich sage mal so grob
nein. Also es ist leider so, dass auch im Gesundheitswesen das, was du ansprichst, häufig
relativ schlechte Passwörter verwendet werden und die auch an Stellen liegen, wo sie nicht
liegen sollten. Da müssen wir noch sehr viel daran arbeiten, auch diesen Datensicherheitsgedanken
unter Ärzten zu tragen. Ah, andere geht los. Oder wir unter anderem auch arbeiten.
Könnt ihr das machen? Andere geht los. Super. Bahnmining. So, jetzt ist es wirklich langsam
voll. Wir brauchen jetzt noch mal die letzten freien Plätze. Wo ist denn noch was frei?
Steht denn noch mal auf? Auch die Aluhut-Fraktion da hinten. Ist ja die Aluhut-Fraktion, die
Aluhüter alles. Ansonsten ganz außen, genau, die ganzen Äußeren. Hier ist es schon fast
voll, aber hier auf der Seite noch ganz außen gibt es noch Plätze. Und wo sind die Flat-Earthler,
wenn die Aluhut-Fraktion schon da ist? Wo sind noch alle Plätze? Sind schon drin Plätze
oder sind wir schon defragmentiert? Hinten sehe ich noch Hände, hier in dem Block. Und
gibt es auf der Tribüne hinten auch noch Plätze frei oder ist da alles voll? Ja, noch einzelne.
Also schaut mal, wo die Hände hochgehen, da bitte noch hinsetzen, die Richtung steuern.
Ist ja fast wie in der Schule. Bitte nach vorne rücken. Ich darf jetzt nicht. Das ist
ja live. Ich darf jetzt gar nicht Pause drücken. Also wir haben hier auch die Möglichkeit,
in den Gängen zu sitzen. Das kennt ihr vielleicht von vollen Zügen. Gut übergeleitet. Hier
vorne noch erste Klasse, auch das, genau, mit extra Beinfreiheit, genau, Premium-Paket.
Alter, was geht mit dem Mikro ab? Hier in der ersten Klasse werden die, die auf den Gängen
sitzen, ja mit voller Zugnummer und Punktungsklasse auf dem Twitter von Marketing genannt. Ja,
genau. Ich habe noch eine Kleinigkeit für die Menschen, die hier vorne sitzen. Wir
werden nachher noch mal ein bisschen was Besonderes machen, bevor der Talk losgeht. Und die Kamera
wird so auf die Bühne gerichtet sein, dass eure Hinterköpfe zu sehen sein werden. Und
wenn ihr das nicht möchtet, müsstet ihr euch noch mal ein Blatt suchen. Ich würde euch
einen der exklusiven Plätze hier rechts auch anbieten, mit Beinfreiheit. Ansonsten dürft
ihr gerne sitzen bleiben. Okay, das wird eines der Aushänge-Vorträge anscheinend. Der Trend
geht zu Aluhöten. Prima. Wenn sie extra eine Kamera durchfahren lassen, das soll natürlich
voll aussehen. Alter, was geht mit der Kamera ab? Die wird übelst, übelst, wenn nicht mehr
Kamera mit Mikro. Okay, langsam geht's los. Ich mach noch mal einmal ganz kurz. Und wo
ist Russisch? Brauch noch Russisch.
Nicht nur Kokona. Wer ist der Kerl, der am Moderator?
Und jetzt möchte ich alle, die reinkommen, bitten, sich schnell noch einen Platz zu suchen.
Falls es keine Plätze mehr gibt, falls ihr keine Plätze mehr findet, stellt euch unauffällig
an die Randbereiche, sodass die Fluchtwege frei bleiben. Und wir starten in Kürze. Es
ist echt wie in der Schule. Bitte noch nach vorne rücken. Ja, jetzt ist es schön hell.
Alter, das Mikrofon. Puppe 2. Wo ist das Barney-Mode? Aber wir passen
dafür. Ich mach's halt wieder lauter, wenn es anfängt.
Darf man sich nicht auf den Teppich setzen, ist es zu bequem.
Den Bahn-AP-Vortrag hab ich letztes Jahr gesehen.
Haha, die Aluhüte.
Sag mal Leute, jetzt, äh, nachdem ihr aktuell, weil er gerade Aluhüte sagt, nachdem ihr
aktuell halt auch wieder sehr viel so Flat Earth und sowas angesagt ist. Wie sieht's
eigentlich mit Hol-Erde aus? Das ist nicht mehr so im Trend, oder? Also ich glaube,
wenn ich mal, wenn ich so abwägen müsste, dann ist Flat Earth eindeutig gerade beliebter.
Hol-Erde ist nicht mehr so angesagt, oder? Ja, Echsenmenschen natürlich auch, darf man
nicht vergessen. Echsenmenschen, nein, Obama ist kein Echsenmensch, Homeworld, das ist
falsch. Der Bodyguard von, du musst dir das schon richtig angucken, das Video, ja? Der
Bodyguard von Obama ist ein Echsenmensch. So sieht's aus. Tja, so ist es, ne? Da fährt
der Zug nicht los. Donut-Earth, aber auch nicht schlecht. NNF, muss ich da draufdrücken.
Der Osten meldet sich zurück. Wuhu, wuhu. Oh Gott. Und wir fahren, fahren, fahren mit
der Eisenbahn. Ja, ich bin Operator, es tut mir leid, ich konnte das mit dem Mikrofon
so nicht direkt. Erstmal, unglaublich, auf was für einem Weltraumbahnhof wir hier irgendwie
gelandet sind in Leipzig. Was gehen die jetzt ab? Oh mein Gott. Und wie lange sitzen Sie
jetzt hier? Oh, ist das einer, der lustig sein will, zwischendurch? Stop, please. Das
ist echt Grinch. Ja, Bruder, was los, ey? Oh Gott, das ist so fremdschäm, cringy, ey.
Ein Träumchen, die ganzen Jahre, das müssen ja unheimlich viele Erlebnisse und Erfahrungen
hier gewesen sein. Wir von der Image-Orga, das ist ja toll. Erzählen Sie mal, weil wir
machen eine Kunden-Zufriedenheit-Umfrage. Ja, also, Bahnfahren mit dem Kongressexpress
ist wirklich toll. Man ist umgeben von lauter Engeln und alles ist flauschig und man hat
ja auch einen guten Ausblick so in die Zukunft. Bisschen lauter, ich mach, sobald der Vortrag
anfängt, mach ich lauter. Es geht noch gar nicht los. Es geht noch gar nicht los, Leute.
Oh, sind hier alle voll dabei. Oh, jetzt geht's los, gleich. Jetzt geht's los. Oh, das tut
weh. Das tut richtig weh. Oh, yeah.
Das ist echt krass. You got that?
Da ist doch glatt einer, ja wunderbar, zugreifen solange es noch frisch ist, weil wir haben jetzt das AAA-Programm gemacht.
AAA steht für Announcement, Attention und dann Acquire.
Wahnsinn, analoge Sitzplatzanzeiger.
Bei dem Chaos schaue ich doch mal in der Farbplan-App, ob ich mal einen Anschluss habe.
Okay, geht's los?
Ja, aber wir werden ja nicht irgendwie der Chaos Communication Express,
wenn ich Open Sword, Open API, Open alles, Menschen sind hier offen.
Okay, es geht noch nicht los.
Wir entwickeln die Sachen, die wir brauchen einfach selber und dieser Spirit ist das, was unser Unternehmen,
unsere Chaos Communication Kongress AG auch zu dem bringt, was sie heute ist.
Ach man, kein Netz, ich lock mich mal ins...
Ja, das ist gescriptet, das macht es aber auch nicht besser.
Kein Netz, also kannst du dir vorstellen, können sie sich vorstellen...
Ist das jetzt irgendwie das Comedy-Intro-Programm oder wie?
Ja, okay, auf geht's.
Es ist 2 minutes ago gestartet übrigens.
Haben wir es.
Es wird immer schlimmer.
So, geht's los?
Ah, jetzt kommt das Intro.
Jetzt können wir auch laut machen.
Viel Spaß.
Klapper, klapper.
Okay, er sieht noch genauso aus wie die Jahre davor, man erkennt ihn eindeutig.
Also ich glaube, so geil bin ich noch niemals eingeleitet worden.
Ja, herzlich willkommen euch allen hier auch, herzlich willkommen an die Leute im Stream.
Und an die Aluhüte im Besonderen.
Die Aluhüte glühen aber leider noch nicht, vielleicht kriegen wir das im Verlaufe dieses Vortrages doch hin.
Mein Name ist David Krise, ich bin Informatiker aus der Nähe von Bonn.
Mit dem richtigen Leben ist es mein Beruf, interessante Sachen in größeren Datenmengen zu finden.
Und neudeutsch heißt das Data Scientist.
Das führt sich zum Beruf, habe ich verschiedene Hobbyprojekte und manchmal nehme ich mir eins davon raus und halte darüber hier einen Vortrag.
Ich bin Rheinländer und bei uns sagt man, ab zweimal ist es Tradition und beim dritten Mal ist es Brauchtum.
Ich bin jetzt das dritte Mal hier, das ist also schon voll Brauchtum.
Und ich freue mich, dass es so oft geklappt hat.
Unsere Geschichte heute beginnt im Jahr 2018.
Hat auch immer gute Vorträge gemacht bisher.
Am Ende des Jahres 2018 hat nämlich die Bahn gesagt, rund 75% ihrer Fernzüge seien pünktlich gewesen.
Schön gerechnet.
Also muss man erstmal wissen, was ist denn pünktlich.
Und die Bahn errechnet das folgendermaßen.
Die sagen, wenn ein Zug bei einem Stopp weniger als 6 Minuten zu spät ankommt, dann ist der pünktlich.
Das ist wirklich die Definition.
Kleiner 6 Minuten, ist echt so.
Und dann errechnen sie den Prozentsatz, bei denen das der Fall ist.
Und das wären bei knapp 75% in 2018 so der Fall gewesen.
Und das hat mich in meiner persönlichen Erfahrung irgendwie gestört.
Ist so.
In den letzten Jahren bin ich quer durch Deutschland gereist, davon relativ häufig mit der Bahn.
Und dann habe ich in meine Mailbox geguckt und für mehr als die Hälfte meiner Fahrten habe ich diese E-Mail von verspätungsalarm.bahn.de.
Der habe ich gar nicht eingeschaltet.
Und da dachte ich, ich bin wohl dieser eine Typ, der aufpassen muss, nicht vom Blitz getroffen zu werden, während er den 6er im Lotto abholt.
Und ich wollte das dann genauer wissen, also habe ich mal in die Statistiken geguckt, die auf der Webseite der Bahn sind.
Und dann habe ich gesehen, da sind kaum welche.
Und die Bahn bietet auf ihrer Webseite nur die Prozent der pünktlichen Stops pro Monat an.
Fürs Gesamtnetz.
Die pünktlichen Stops pro Monat.
Allein schon in Nah- und Fernverkehr.
Und das ist zusammengefasst, damit kann man nichts anfangen.
Man kann da nicht nach bestimmten Verbindungen filtern.
Man kann auch nicht gucken, bei welchen Bahnhöfen die Performance besonders schlecht ist oder gut ist.
Und alles, was interessant ist oder was ich interessant fand, das geht nicht.
Da habe ich am 8. Januar begonnen, die deutsche Bahn zu Vorratsdaten speichern.
Und in diesen...
Ah, Chat-Overlay.
Stimmt.
Und in diesen Datensatz gucken wir heute rein.
Und wir werten das auch nicht nur aus, sondern ich werde auch ein bisschen Zeit darauf verwenden, euch grob zu erklären, wie man so ein Datenprojekt angeht und worauf man achten muss.
Wie man vor allem merkt, ob man Vertrauen in die Daten haben kann.
Das muss ja nicht sein, dass alles stimmt, was man so runterlädt.
Doch, immer.
Über den ganzen Vortrag hinweg gebe ich euch immer so ein paar, wie nenne ich das, Praxistipps.
Die ihr mit nach Hause nehmt und an die ihr denken könnt, wenn ihr eine Bahnfahrt bucht.
Und Disclaimer vorweg, ich habe mit der Bahn nicht über die Auswertung gesprochen.
Behaltet im Hinterkopf, am Ende ist das ein kleines Hobbyprojekt.
Und es kann durchaus sein, dass ich Fehler gemacht habe.
Aber da wir auch noch über die Vertrauenswürdigkeit der Daten reden, könnt ihr selbst entscheiden, ob ihr meinen Daten vertraut oder nicht.
So, und wir gucken uns jetzt endlich mal an, wie die Daten aussehen.
Hier sehen wir eine fiktive Fahrt eines ICE.
Ich gebe euch mal kurz fünf Sekunden für den ersten Überblick und danach erkläre ich die.
Fährt los in München.
Drei Sekunden reicht auch.
Dann überspringt er den Flughafen.
Fährt in München los und jede weitere Zeile ist ein Stopp.
Und irgendwann ist er am Ziel angekommen.
Hier Bergen auf Rügen.
Und eine Fahrt ist also die Sequenz aller Stops, die der Zug von Anfang bis Ende macht.
Danach ist das eine neue Fahrt.
Hier sind die Verspätungen pro Stopp.
Der Zug ist mit sechs Minuten Verspätung abgefahren.
Und nach der Messmethode der Bahn wäre der so gerade als verspätet zu werden an diesem Stopp.
Und dann schwanken die Verspätungen.
In Erfurt sind wir auch mal sechs Minuten zu früh dran gewesen.
Die Verspätung ist negativ.
Das passiert.
In der Regel heißt das übrigens, dass der Zug dann einfach länger bleibt und nicht auch zu früh wieder abfährt.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Der Stopp fällt aus.
Das ist für'n Arsch.
In 20 Jahren werde ich diese Witze immer noch machen können.
Wenn der Flughafen immer mal fertig ist, dann hält er da vielleicht auch.
Es ist aber toll, dass der schon da drin steht.
Und diese Stops aller Fahrten sind die Grundlage unserer Daten.
Meine Tabelle hat 25 Millionen Zeilen.
25 Millionen Stops von irgendwelchen Zügen.
Das sind alle Stops im Fernverkehr von 8. Januar bis jetzt und auch der Nahverkehr.
Aber der nur an den Fernbahnhöfen, komme ich gleich noch zu.
Und die Tabelle hat auch verschiedenste Spalten.
Die, die ich hier vorführe und noch einige mehr.
Und wir können in einzelne Orte reingucken, einzelne Fahrten reingucken, in Zeiträume reingucken.
Wir können auch kompliziertere Auswertungen fahren.
Machen wir auch heute noch.
Und zum Anfang machen wir mal ein paar ganz einfache Sachen mit den Daten.
Das ist nicht mit euch zu langweilen, aber wir müssen erst mal reinkommen, den Datensatz kennenlernen und so weiter.
Und wir sortieren jetzt die ganze Tabelle von Stops.
25 Millionen Stops nach Bahnhöfen.
Und dann ermitteln wir die Anzahl der Stops für jeden Bahnhof über das ganze Jahr hinweg.
Und jeder Bubble hier ist so ein Bahnhof mit Fernverkehr.
Und davon haben wir um die 350 Stück.
Das sind die wichtigen.
Und die Größe der Bubble gibt die Anzahl der erfassten Halter für den Bahnhof wieder.
Und zwar für alles, was da fährt, Fern- und Nahverkehr.
Und der größte, was das angeht, ist Köln Hauptbahnhof.
Auch gut dabei.
Mit im Moment 380.000 Stops in der Datenbank.
Ich habe die Top 6 mal in der Karte beschriftet.
Warum genau die Top 6?
Weil der sechste Bahnhof genau Hamburg-Dammtor ist.
Und das wollte ich euch nicht vorenthalten.
Das war unser letzter Kongressbahnhof.
Der Bahnhof Leipzig.
Das ist übrigens deutlich, deutlich kleiner.
Inklusive Nahverkehr haben wir hier so 60.000 Stops im Jahr.
Und überhaupt nur ein paar hundert Fernverkehr.
Wo wir schon dabei sind, machen wir jetzt was aus Kundensicht interessantes.
Und färben mal die Bahnhöfe ein.
Und zwar nach der Pünktlichkeit.
Nach dem Prozentsatz der Pünktlichkeit der dortigen Stops im Fernverkehr.
Das ist die Pünktlichkeit.
Knallrot ist 60 Prozent.
Knallblau ist 90 Prozent.
Und dazwischen farblos, das ist ungefähr der Durchschnitt bei 75.
Als erstes sieht man, in Ostdeutschland ist quasi alles blau.
Ja, ich bin sicher, das sind diese...
Na gut, wir fahren die Strecke.
Das ist die Strecke Köln-Frankfurt hier.
Köln-Frankfurt ist halt voll.
Ich bin sicher, das sind diese blühenden Landschaften.
Von denen alt Kanzler Kohl immer sprach.
In Nordrhein-Westfalen ist so ziemlich alles rot.
Köln hat nur so 66 Prozent Pünktlichkeit.
Bonn ist wirklich eins der Schlusslichter mit 59 Prozent.
Das sind die beiden Bahnhöfe, über die ich oft fahre.
Generell, der ganze dicht besiegelte Raum in Nordrhein-Westfalen ist ziemlich schlimm dran.
Und ich habe euch ja gesagt, dass ich das ganze Projekt überhaupt erst gestartet habe,
weil ich dachte, die Statistik der Bahn wäre falsch,
weil meine Züge so häufig unpünktlich sind.
Die simple Wahrheit ist, ich wohne nur schlecht.
Hamburg oben ist auch schlimm.
Das finde ich auch gerecht.
Warum soll ich der Einzige sein?
Irgendwo bei 60 Prozent, je nachdem, welchen Bahnhof man erwischt.
Das sieht da jetzt röter aus, als es ist, weil die Dinger transparent sind.
Und was die Pünktlichkeit angeht, haben wir uns mit Leipzig-Messe definitiv verbessert.
Also wir sind hier so bei 80 Prozent oder etwas mehr.
Ganz wichtig, ich zeichne jetzt überall, wo es nicht anders dran steht, nur noch den Fernverkehr an.
Überhaupt wird der ganze Vortrag primär über den Fernverkehr gehen,
weil über das wird meistens berichtet in den Medien.
Mich interessiert der Nahverkehr mehr.
Aber wenn ich sage, dass ich hier primär über den Fernverkehr heute rede,
dann muss ich auch fair sein und das Folgende sagen.
Der Nahverkehr, den wir jetzt auslassen,
erreicht fast flächendeckend Pünktlichkeitswerte von besser als 90 Prozent.
Verhalte das bitte über den Rest des Vortrages im Hinterkopf.
Die Bahn hat auch gute Seiten.
Da bin ich mir bei mir nicht so sicher.
Da bringt der Nahverkehr eine ziemliche Menge Leute jeden Tag zu ihrem Job.
Da geht sicher auch mal was schief, aber deutlich weniger als im Fernverkehr.
Ich hoffe, die Leute von der Bahn hören zu und hören das jetzt gerade.
Ich wohne schlecht, genau.
Wir ändern jetzt noch mal die Ansicht.
Die Pünktlichkeiten pro Bahnhof waren ja interessant für den Kunden.
Aber wenn man ein bisschen analytisch was machen will und bei der Bahn arbeitet,
dann ist doch das Interessante, welche Bahnhöfe richtig viel Verspätung generieren,
also dem Netz hinzufügen. Und das ist die Ansicht.
Ganz schlimm sind große Bahnhöfe mit vielen Stops,
die gleichzeitig jedem Zug, der da anhält, noch ein bisschen Verspätung mit auf den Weg geben.
Die fünf schlimmsten sind Hamburg, Köln, Frankfurt Flughafen, Mannheim.
Oh, Frankfurt Flughafen ist wirklich scheiße.
Hier sind alle mit mehr als 50.000 hinzugefügten Verspätungsminuten im Messzeitraum.
Und der Spitzenreiter ist Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof mit 93.000 generierten Verspätungsminuten.
Das wundert mich nicht.
Ich höre, wir haben eine Frankfurt-Fraktion. Wie seid ihr hergekommen?
Die sind heute erst angekommen.
Mein täglicher Bahnhof, Leute.
Ich hoffe, ihr habt euch nicht gehetzt, zweiter Tag abends.
Es gibt aber auch Bahnhöfe, die funktionieren so gut,
dass sie insgesamt Verspätungen aus dem Netz rausnehmen.
Die Top 3 sind Bremen, Berlin Hauptbahnhof und Berlin Spandau.
Das hat mich sehr kalt erwischt, dass mir völlig unverhofft ein Nachweis dieser Größenordnung gelungen ist.
Es gibt tatsächlich etwas an Berlin, das funktioniert.
Wir machen weiter.
Hier seht ihr im Vergleich, sonst artet das aus.
Hier seht ihr mal im Vergleich, wie viele Fahrten es im Nahverkehr, Fernverkehr und von Drittanbietern gibt.
Wie ihr seht, ist das weitaus meister der Nahverkehr.
Hier orange sind mehr als fünf Millionen Fahrten im Datensatz.
Dagegen gibt es nur circa eine Viertelmillion Fahrten im Fernverkehr.
Der ist hier blau und es gibt noch ziemlich viele Fahrten von Drittanbietern.
Wir dröseln das jetzt mal in einzelne Zugarten auf,
einfach damit wir sehen, was es so gibt, bevor wir richtig einsteigen.
Wir sehen jetzt, dass sich der Nahverkehr aufspaltet in die drei dicksten Bubbeln.
Regionalbahn, Regionalexpress, S-Bahn und der Fernverkehr in ICE Intercity.
Das ist IC und Euro City IC.
Die Abkürzungen verwende ich auch im Folgenden.
Diese vergleichsweise kleinen blauen Punkte, das sind die eigentlich interessanten Zugarten für heute.
Das sind nämlich die Züge, die quer durch Deutschland fahren.
Da kann man richtig was sehen.
Jetzt gehen wir einen Schritt weiter.
Wir nehmen diese für uns relevanten Zugarten her, also ICE Intercity, Euro City.
Und dann schauen wir einfach mal, welche Zugart generell am spätesten dran ist.
Damit man gleich weiß, wo man ausweichen muss.
Ich wiederhole nochmals, die Prozentzahl der Stops, die maximal sechs Minuten zu spät sind, sind pünktlich.
Im Fernverkehr am pünktlichsten sind die Intercity mit gut 76 Prozent.
Dicht danach folgen die ICE und deutlich dahinter die Euro City.
Davon sind nicht mal 70 Prozent nach der Bahndefinition.
Aber 76 ist auch von A, du kannst dich nicht darauf verlassen.
Das kann ich aus persönlicher Erfahrung bestätigen.
Nach meinem Eindruck ist die Qualität von den Teilen einfach schlechter in jeder Hinsicht.
Die Züge sehen, auch wenn ich damit fahre, immer relativ alt aus.
Aber man muss auch fair sein, die fahren internationaler als der Rest der Züge.
Und wenn die direkt von außen verspätung mitbringen, kann die Bahn da nichts führen.
Und solche Fälle gibt es.
Und es fehlt noch eine Größe, die wir messen können und die wir messen werden.
Für die schweigt sich die Bahn auf ihren Webseiten aus.
Und wenn man sich so konsequent ausschweigt, hat das natürlich zur Folge, dass man sich für eine Analyse bewirbt.
Und das ist der Prozentsatz der Ausfälle.
Und hier ist er. Und das war für mich überraschend.
ICEs sind ja das Flaggschiff der Bahn.
Und anscheinend fallen die mit weitem Abstand am häufigsten aus.
Aber sind trotzdem am pünktlichsten.
ICE gut zwei Prozent, Intercity gut drei Prozent und ICE über fünf Prozent.
Also wenn ihr einen ICE bucht, dann taucht er in einem von zwanzig Mal einfach nicht auf.
Und das fand ich ganz schön stramm.
Mich hat das überraschend.
Mein Praxistipp an euch lautet also, Vorsicht mit den ICEs.
Ich weise fairerweise nochmals darauf hin, dass das eine Auswertung von außen ist.
Es besteht die Möglichkeit, dass das nicht stimmt.
Oder da ewig viele Extrafahrten dann für die Ausfälle gefahren werden, die gar nicht im Plan standen.
Aber alle diese Stops standen in deren Daten explizit als ausgefallen drin.
Die Daten sehen insgesamt realistisch aus.
Und im Spiegel hatten sie auch neulich eine Auswertung, wo sie auf ähnliche Werte kamen.
Also schlage ich vor, wir betrachten das mal als gegeben, bis die Bahn widerspricht.
Übrigens, einer der fettesten nicht ausgefallenen Verspätungen in meinem Datensatz war der ICE 576
von Stuttgart nach Hamburg, und zwar am 17. Oktober 2019.
Der hatte 456 Minuten Verspätung.
What?
Das sind mehr als 7,5 Stunden.
Und der war nicht ausgefallen.
Und um unseren Überblick zu vollenden, gucken wir uns jetzt das Ganze nochmal über die Zeit an.
Hier sehen wir die Fahrten über die Zeit, die ich für den Fernverkehr in der Datenbank habe.
Die können wir uns mal angucken, wie das funktioniert.
Wir sehen, dass wir so um die 800 Fahrten am Tag haben im Fernverkehr.
Die niedersten Zacken sind immer Samstage, die hohen Zacken immer Freitage.
Das ist der Berufsverkehr.
Hier sind Ostern und Pfingsten.
Weihnachten habe ich nicht mehr hingekriegt.
Und was sieht man noch?
Man sieht zum Beispiel, dass ich zwischendurch Mist gebaut habe und ein paar Tage Daten verloren habe.
Wer meinen letzten Vortrag hier gesehen hat, dem wird das bekannt vorkommen.
Ich mache das jeden Vortrag.
Aber ich war besser.
Diesmal war ich so klug.
Und dann habe ich mir ein vernünftiges Download-Monitoring gebaut.
Und dann dachte ich, ich wäre cool.
Und dann habe ich es irgendwie geschafft, den Debian-Server, auf dem das Ganze läuft, komplett zu crashen.
Also der hat gar nicht mehr geantwortet.
Ich musste die Giste hart booten.
Und ich war da gerade in Urlaub und habe das nicht gemerkt.
Also diesmal technischer Tipp für euch.
Baut nicht nur ein Download-Monitoring, sondern lasst das auch noch auf einem anderen Server laufen als den Download selbst.
Es war es dran.
Und weil wir heute ja auf Bahnbewerbung hin die Ausfälle besonders genau machen wollen.
Hier sind die Ausfälle über die Zeit.
Das sind die Prozent der Stops pro Tag, die einfach ausgefallen sind.
Und man sieht sofort zwei fette Spikes.
Hier ist der Orkan Eberhard.
Dieser Orkan ist am 10. März über uns hereingebrochen.
Und am Nachmittag war der der Meinung, es würde jetzt mal reichen mit Bahnverkehr.
Und den gucken wir uns auch noch genauer an.
Und hier ist der heiße Stops des Jahres, der Hitzewelle dieses Jahr.
Und generell sieht man hier, wenn ihr mal so ein bisschen genauer guckt, dass es im Hochsommer eine stark erhöhte Ausfallrate gibt.
Wie kommt das? Klimaanlage höchter.
Die Ausfälle nach Zeit zerlegen wir jetzt nochmal in die relevanten Zugarten, bevor der alles vorwegnimmt.
Und das machen wir jetzt nicht mehr auf der Basis von Tagen, sondern von Wochen.
Das ist einfach etwas glattern.
Ja guck mal, da wo es warm ist, krackt das Zeug ab.
Und da sieht man erstmal, was für ein fettes Problem die mit den ICEs im Sommer haben.
Und ihr seht, wie die Ausfälle der ICEs im Sommer im Vergleich zu den anderen Zugarten richtig stark nach oben ausbrechen.
Das sind so um die 8% Ausfallquote.
Fast an jedem 12. Stopp taucht so ein ICE in der Warmzeit dann einfach nicht auf.
Da kann man sich nicht drauf verlassen.
Und in der Woche vom 22. Juli, in der ganzen Woche, sind mehr als 10% aller ICE-Stops ausgefallen.
Ihr kennt ja die vier Feinde der Deutschen Bahn.
Ich weiß nicht wie euch das geht, aber das geht bei mir über die Fehlertoleranz.
Also wenn das jeden Sommer so ist, hier mein nächster Praxistipp für euch.
Vorsicht mit ICEs im Sommer.
Und jetzt wo es kälter wird, fängt das auch wieder so an.
Aber wenn man das so anguckt, wir müssen noch ein bisschen abwarten.
Es ist noch nicht raus, ob das wirklich so wird.
Also in zwei, drei Monaten wissen wir mehr, wenn es richtig kalt war.
Wir machen jetzt noch zwei kleine Sachen und danach reden wir mal darüber,
wie man so ein Projekt überhaupt aufbaut und was die Grundregeln sind.
Hier ist was Offensichtliches.
Ich habe hier die Stops mal aller Fahrten sortiert nach der Zeit,
die die Zugfahrt nahe bereits vor diesem Stopp gedauert hat.
Von links nach rechts steigt die bereits gefahrene Laufzeit vor dem Stopp an.
Hier von 0 bis 500 Minuten. Und was sieht man?
Früher in der Fahrt ist der Prozentsatz der pünktlichen Züge höher.
In der Fahrt sinkt die prozentuale Pünktlichkeit krass ab.
Bei 500 Minuten sind unter 60 Prozent pünktlich.
Klingt logisch, aber ist trotzdem doof.
Das habt ihr euch wahrscheinlich jetzt alle schon selbst gedacht.
Warum sage ich das also? Weil ich die Bahn ein bisschen in Schutz nehmen möchte.
Man sieht nämlich häufiger in den Medien irgendwelche Untersuchungen von Fahrten
zwischen weit entfernten Metropolen.
Und da werden dann unglaublich schlechte Pünktlichkeiten gemessen.
Und wenn ihr sowas seht, lasst mich euch sagen, die machen die Bahn schlimmer als sie ist,
weil sie durch Weiterentfernung eben nur den Datenteil mit der hohen Verspätung auswählen.
Und ganz ehrlich, also die häufigen Probleme mit den japanischen Hochgeschwindigkeitszügen
sind aus meiner Sicht auch einfach Stuss.
Die verbinden in Japan nur die absolut riesigen Metropolen.
Die haben ein komplettes Schienennetz für sich alleine.
Der Fernverkehr der Bahn muss sich das Netz mit Güter und Nahverkehr teilen
und bindet auch noch die Mittelzentren mit an.
Also das ist nicht vergleichbar. So viel müssen wir schon sein.
Ich muss jetzt mal eine Tüte zumachen, sonst weiß ich zu viel davon.
Vorsicht mit Zügen, die bereits lange unterwegs sind.
Ihr könnt ja, wenn ihr bucht, sehen, was das für eine Zuglinie ist und woher die kommt.
Ihr könnt ja also mit einbeziehen.
Als nächstes habe ich mich gefragt, ab welcher Verspätung wird es nicht mehr besser?
Wer ist das? Das ist David Gryll.
Ist der mit dem Xerox-Vortrag von vor ein paar Jahren?
Und das hier ist von links nach rechts aufgetragen.
Links stehen die wenig verspäteten Stops, rechts die mit mehr Verspätung.
Und dann habe ich geguckt, wie viel Prozent bauen auf dem Rest ihrer Fahrt 5% der Verspätung ab
und existieren noch, also sind nicht ausgefallen.
Hört sich jetzt kompliziert an, aber kurz, wie viel Prozent werden noch mal spürbar besser?
Oder war es das jetzt?
Und wie man sieht, ist, dass bei Verspätung unter 40 Minuten noch mehr als die Hälfte der Züge
am Ende der Fahrt besser dastehen als jetzt gerade.
Und ab 40 Minuten Verspätung, da ist eine gut sichtbare Stufe in den Daten.
Die einzige, da scheint die Bahn die Dinger irgendwie aufzugeben.
Ab da wird es in der Mehrzahl der Fälle bis zum Fahrtende nicht mehr besser.
Woran das liegen könnte, darauf kommen wir gleich auch noch.
Praxistipp für euch also, ab einer Verspätung von 40 Minuten erweckt ein anderes Transportmittel.
Sieht schlecht aus, ja.
Würde sich auch über meine Erfahrung so decken.
Was jetzt?
Stream, please.
Streamrip.
Stream ist futsch.
Das liegt nicht an mir.
Das liegt an denen.
Guck da.
Die Bahn ist schuld.
Muss nicht F5 drücken, weil ich habe es in drei Tabs aufgehabt und es ist kaputt.
Aber das Ding hat generell Probleme.
Wir müssen jetzt Daten ein paar Stückchen vor und zurück.
Leider müssen wir beides für jeden Bahnhof einzeln abrufen.
Und das bedeutet, wir können uns nicht am Schluss einfach ein Jahr Daten ziehen,
sondern wir müssen wirklich über das ganze Jahr hinweg mit einer Struktur,
sehr häufig Daten abrufen, die sich überlappen.
Solche Szenarios findet man relativ häufig.
Das funktioniert dann so, dass man die Downloads einfach erstmal wegspeichert
und konkrete Werte auslesen und Duplikate raussortieren.
Das ist dann einfach alles später.
Und jetzt machen wir mal eine Nebenrechnung auf.
Wir haben 6.500 Bahnhöfe in Deutschland.
Für jeden müssen wir einzeln beides abrufen, also mal zwei.
Und jetzt sagen wir mal, wir machen das alle 10 Minuten für Fahrplan und Änderungen.
Und das macht dann 6.600 mal 2 mal 144.
Das sind knapp 2 Millionen Abrufe am Tag.
Das ist der Chaos-Communication-Kongress vom Chaos-Computer-Club.
Da gibt es jede Menge solcher Vorträge.
Das passt sich auch nicht mehr von alleine.
Für das ganze Jahr wären das dann 14 Terabyte, 700 Millionen Requests.
In diesem Moment kriegen die Admins der Bahn vermutlich einen Herzanfall.
Welche Admins?
Wenn die damit fertig sind, dann werden die ihre Logs schauen, welche Abrufe von mir sind.
Und dann werden die ihren Anwalt anrufen, um mir eine riesige Rechnung zu schicken.
Aber die enttäuschen wir jetzt.
Natürlich habe ich das nicht so gemacht.
Erstmal hätte ich das dann alles speichern und verarbeiten müssen.
Das ist viel zu aufwendig.
Und zweitens ist eine Sache ganz wichtig, wenn ihr so etwas macht.
Ihr müsst den Traffic minimieren.
Und zwar aus zwei Gründen.
Das sind die Punkte 2 und 3.
Punkt 2 handelt verantwortungsvoll.
Das bedeutet, dass ihr bitte nicht so viel Traffic erzeugt,
dass ihr die Infrastruktur des Ziels abwirkt oder irgendwie unnötige Kosten verursacht.
Das ist jetzt realistischer, als das sich anhört.
Vielleicht nicht bei der Bahn.
Aber beispielsweise bei den Justizportalen in Deutschland müsst ihr aufpassen.
Die sind erstaunlich schwach auf der Brust.
Da habe ich gehört.
Da sieht man mal, was es ausmacht, wenn man jemanden hat, der guten Vortrag halten kann.
Meine Lösung dafür, ich rufe maximal stündlich ab.
Und auch nur die ca. 350 Fernbahnhöfe.
Das sind anstatt der 2 Millionen sofort nur noch 16.000 Requests am Tag.
In der Regel ist es noch mal deutlich geringer, weil man das adaptiv machen kann.
Das war ein Höllenritt.
Jetzt haben wir schon diverse Praxis abkriegt.
Ich schlage keinen Herzanfall mehr.
Aber die sind trotzdem enttäuscht.
Punkt 3 fliegt unter dem Radar.
Das soll ja eine Weihnachtsüberraschung bleiben.
Das wäre es natürlich schlecht gewesen, wenn die Millionenabrufe vom Server deKriesel kommen.
Das fällt nämlich irgendwann auf.
Die Lösung hierfür ist, ihr schickt die Abfragen über tausende Zwischenstationen in der ganzen Welt.
In der Fachsprache heißen die anonyme Proxys.
Die Maus geht nicht mehr weg.
Wenn ich Massen von Daten runter lade, dann sieht das für das Ziel aus wie ein Grundrauschen von winzigen Abfragen, die von der ganzen Welt kommen.
Viele von euch werden das auch so machen.
Niemand sieht mich, aber in Wirklichkeit laufen die Daten dann einfach im Hintergrund auf meinen Servern wieder zusammen, sofern ich sie nicht crashe.
An dieser Stelle hören die Admins der Bahn vermutlich auf, meine Abfragen in ihren Logs zu suchen.
Und ich freue mich, dass die jetzt wieder voll beim Vortrag dabei sind.
Damit ich euch nicht abschrecke, so einen Aufwand müsst ihr nicht bei jedem Datenprojekt treiben.
Das war vielleicht ein bisschen overkill, weil ich das mal ausprobieren wollte mit den Proxys.
Punkt 4.
Es kann passieren, dass ihr nicht sicher seid, was ihr rechtlich dürft, ohne dran zu kommen.
Die meisten von unter uns sind keine Juristen und manche AGB sind auch einfach mies formuliert.
Und wenn ihr nicht sicher seid, was ihr dürft, dann fragt einen Anwalt, der für euch die AGB liest.
Es gibt im Internet Portale, wo ihr für schmales Geld Anwälten Fragen stellen könnt.
Und danach kriegt ihr eine rechtsverbindliche Antwort.
Wenn das nicht stimmt, haftet ihr.
Und bei mir kam dann leider raus, dass ich bei der Bahn lieber eine schriftliche Genehmigung erfragen sollte.
Und das war so ein Moment, wo ich kurz dachte, dass das Projekt vielleicht aber kippe steht.
Die haben zugestimmt, die Bahn.
Das wäre schade gewesen, weil ich mir vorab schon ein bisschen Arbeit gemacht hatte.
Also lest zuerst die AGB.
Und Punkt 5.
Habt trotz Hindernissen den Mut, es einfach zu tun.
Der ist live, Saito.
Ich hab das bevorken und wirklich bei der Bahn nachgefragt, ob ich automatisiert Daten drunter laden
und darüber zum Beispiel einen kleinen Community-Vortrag halten darf.
Ja, ich würde den auch nicht sagen, ich würde den auch nicht sagen,
ich will einen Vortrag halten vor, keine Ahnung, was sind das, 500 Leute, 1000 Leute?
Ohne weitere Auflagen.
Ohne Auflagen und ob sie wirklich so offen sind oder einfach vergessen haben zu googeln, weiß ich nicht.
Aber ganz ehrlich, das könnte jetzt mal ein Applaus für die Bahn wert sein, weil das ist sportlich.
Nicht schlecht.
Ich hoffe, die hören zu.
Und Punkt 6.
Seid fair bei der Auswertung.
Wenn ihr Daten für ein Jahr habt zum Beispiel, dann sucht ihr nicht die vier Monate raus,
wo die Bahn besonders unpünktlich war, damit ihr fiesere Dinge behaupten könnt.
Kein Kreischen für irgendwelche Likes.
Das ist aber nicht sehr YouTube-konform.
Punkt 7.
Guckt, ob ihr euren eigenen Daten vertrauen könnt.
Und das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Und ich führ das jetzt mal vor und dann könnt ihr entscheiden, ob ihr meinen Daten vertraut.
Und außerdem ist das jetzt unsere Ausrede, dass wir diesen Einschub verlassen
und endlich wieder in die Daten reingucken.
Am besten schafft ihr Vertrauen in euren Datensatz, indem ihr mal eine Analyse komplett nachbaut,
die die Quelle des Datensatzes, also hier die Bahn, schon mal gemacht hat.
Und die Bahn gibt auf ihrer Webseite ja pro Monat die Prozentzahl der pünktlichen Stops an.
Und in ihren Dokumenten steht auch, wie sie das exakt ausrechnen.
Und die habe ich einfach genauso nachgebaut und siehe da.
Das sieht wirklich fast genauso aus.
Die zwei größten Abweichungen sind die folgenden.
Im Januar messe ich die Bahn einen halben Prozentpunkt schlechter als sie ist.
Das liegt vermutlich daran, dass ich erst am 8. Januar angefangen habe, Daten aufzunehmen.
Und im September 0,8 Prozentpunkte.
Das ist da, wo mir ein paar Tage fehlen.
Ansonsten scheint bei mir die Bahn sogar generell minimal besser wegzukommen.
Die gleichen Werte werdet ihr nie kriegen.
Die meisten Abweichungen sind hier so um 0,1 Prozentpunkte.
Aber für eine Messung von außen ist das verdammt akkurat.
Wenn eure Werte mit denen des Ziels so übereinstimmen, dann seid ihr auf einem guten Weg.
Das heißt externe Verifikation, weil wir was externes zum Vergleichen hatten.
Jetzt kommt die interne.
Das bedeutet, ihr guckt in den Datensatz rein, ob da alles realistisch aussieht.
Zum Beispiel in Hand der Tageszeiten.
Jeder Punkt hier ist wieder ein Fernverkehrsbahnhof.
Das ist der Tagesbeginn, 0 Uhr vom 9. März diesen Jahres.
Ich gehe jetzt die Zeitstunde durch, dann sehen wir, wie es für die Bahn aussieht.
Die Bahnhofspunkte schwellen an, wenn in der Stunde mehr Stops stattgefunden haben.
Die Farbe markiert die Ausfälle. Blau ist wenig, rot ist viel.
Dunkelrot entspricht 50 Prozent oder mehr Ausfällen.
Und es ist jetzt 0 Uhr.
Und man sieht, dass noch einige wenige Züge des Vortages sozusagen unterwegs sind.
Das sind die Lumpensammler sozusagen. Und das wird jetzt weniger werden.
Und die Nachtruhe kehrt ein. Die Zeit vergeht.
Nachtruhe. Und hier erwacht ein neuer Tag.
Jetzt ist so langsam Vollbetrieb. Es ist 8 Uhr.
Wir sehen hier ein paar punktuelle Ereignisse, die für Ausfälle sorgen.
Das sind die roten Flecken. Das Unwetter oder so passiert.
Keine Notizen.
Es ist Mittag.
Jetzt wird es wieder weniger. Der Tag geht seinem Ende entgegen.
Die letzte Stunde des Tages. Ein neuer Tag beginnt.
Es ist der 10. März. Wir sehen wieder die letzten Züge, bevor die Nachtruhe beginnt.
Alles schläft.
Der Tag wird älter. Es ist 6 Uhr. Man sieht schon ein bisschen Treffik.
Es ist 9 Uhr. Wir sind wieder im Vollbetrieb.
Es ist Mittag am 10. März. Und wir erinnern uns, an dem Tag war ja was.
Und hier zeigt der Orkan Eberhard erste Auswirkungen.
Da kann ich mich dran erinnern. Da ist in Frankfurt auch nichts gefahren.
Und hier hat er dann in fast ganz Deutschland den Fernverkehr flach gelegt.
Ich musste die Farbskale erweitern, weil man 50 Prozent Ausfälle normal nicht hat.
Und wir lassen diesen sehr schlechten Tag für die Bahn nun ausklingen.
Weder Fern- noch Nachverkehr.
Und hier ist wieder Mitternacht, die Grenze zum Folgetag.
Eine Störung in der Größenordnung zieht natürlich noch einige Tage messbare Verspätungen und Ausfälle nach sich.
Wenn man das aufplottet, sieht man, dass mehrere Tage runtergehen.
Die spielen wir jetzt aber nicht alle durch. Aber wir sehen, nicht immer ist die Bahn schuld.
Wenn ihr die Daten so auf Plausibilität checkt, dann nutzt unbedingt gute Visualisierungen,
aber am besten gleich mehrere Dimensionen abdecken.
Hier hatten wir Ausfälle, Ort in zwei Dimensionen und die Anzahl der Stops und die Zeit nach Stunde.
Und der beste Apparat zur Mustererkennung, den wir zurzeit haben, das ist nun mal das Gehirn.
Da gibt es nur eine Breitbandleitung und das sind die Augen.
Und wir werden jetzt noch ein paar größere Auswertungen machen.
Und als erstes bitte ich euch dafür, in Gedanken die Seiten zu wechseln.
Ihr gebt keine Analysen raus, sondern ihr lest welche.
Das ist ein neuer Vortrag von ihm, der ist gerade live.
Da ist es immer sehr wichtig zu riechen, worüber die anderen mit euch nicht reden möchten.
Und bei Firmen findet man das raus, indem man deren Kennzahlen genau anguckt.
Die Bahn hat zum Beispiel gesagt, sie wollte dieses Jahr 76,5 pünktliche Stops haben.
Daran wollen sie sich messen.
Dieser Bericht ist aus dem Januar 2019.
Anfang Dezember 2019 haben sie das Ziel dann kassiert.
Es werden nur unter 75 pünktliche Stops im Fernverkehr.
In meinen Daten sind es im Moment noch knapp über 75 Prozent.
Aber trotzdem, das Ziel wird verfehlt.
Aber 76 ist halt auch lächerlich.
Aber was aufhält, ist, dass sich die Bahn halt so ausfällt.
Ich sag das schon ganz komisch ausschweigt.
Und jetzt bitte ich mal um Handzeichen an euch.
Stellt euch vor, ihr steht am Bahnsteig.
Und der Zug fällt einfach aus.
Ihr steht da mit Lärmdick.
Der kommt einfach nicht.
Und ihr dürft jetzt entscheiden, ist der pünktlich oder unpünktlich.
Wer von euch sollte sagen, der ist eher pünktlich?
Die Bahn sagt, der ist pünktlich.
Zwei Hände.
Drei im Saal von 5000 Mann.
Okay, ist messbar.
Wer von euch würde sagen, der Zug ist eher unpünktlich?
Das sind so ziemlich alle.
Und so sehe ich das eigentlich auch.
Und jetzt schauen wir mal in die Unterlagen der Bahn dazu.
Ihr müsst das nicht lesen.
Ich lese euch das vor.
Komplettausfälle oder Teilausfälle werden, wie übrigens bei den anderen europäischen Bahnen auch, nicht in Statistiken eingerechnet.
Zum einen ist es schwierig, dafür ein sinnvolles mathematisches Modell zu hinterlegen.
Welche Pünktlichkeit ordnet man einem Zug zu, wenn er an einer bestimmten Stelle seiner Fahrt ausfällt?
Wir können binär messen, ob drei von acht Stops pünktlich oder nicht pünktlich sind.
Aber mit Ausfallen nicht ausgefallen, das geht nicht.
Und zum anderen liegt die sogenannte Erfüllungsquote aller täglich Verkehrsenden, DB-Personenzüge, über 99 Prozent im Jahresschnitt.
Sowohl für Fern- als auch für Nachverkehr.
Also Punkt eins.
Da möchte ich als erstes mal zu anmerken, dass ich das in der Sache nicht nachvollziehen kann, weil wir schon gesehen hatten,
dass alleine der Fernverkehr eine Ausfallquote von mehr als vier Prozent hat und nicht ein Prozent.
Das heißt, wir haben insgesamt 103 Prozent Fernverkehr.
Aber vor allem, vielleicht ist die Erfüllungsquote auch was anderes, was ich hier nicht verstehe, keine Ahnung.
Aber vor allem so ein ausgefallener Zug, der ist nicht unpünktlich.
Der fällt einfach komplett außer Wertung.
Die Ausfälle werden statistisch verdeckt, weil man sie angeblich nicht statistisch einbauen kann.
Also liebe Leute, ich mache solche Auswertungen ja auch beruflich und da habe ich echt schon manche Ausrede zu hören gekriegt.
Aber das hier, das ist schon krass. Ich nenne sowas den finalen Rettungsstuss.
Das ist eine gute Bezeichnung dafür.
Wenn ihr sowas erzählt kriegt, dann wisst ihr ganz genau, ihr habt es gefunden.
Hier müsst ihr gucken und nicht woanders.
Also helfen wir jetzt mit und wir entwickeln jetzt eine Idee, wie man die Ausfälle doch sinnvoll in die Statistik rein kriegt.
Hier sehen wir eine Zugfahrt mit vier Stops. Die beiden weißen links sind pünktlich, der hellblaue ist unpünktlich, größer 6 Minuten.
Und der rechte in rot ist ganz ausgefallen.
Und im Moment zählt die Bahn einfach alle Stops, die nicht ausgefallen sind und messen davon den Prozentatz der Pünktlichkeit.
Das wären hier 2 von 3, 66 Prozent und ich schlage stattdessen vor.
Wir zählen alle Stops, die geplant waren und messen davon den Prozentatz, der angekommen ist und pünktlich war.
Das wären hier 50 Prozent. Nehmt das nicht auf die leichte Schulter. Das ist jetzt wirklich große Mathematik.
Da reicht 5-Head schon mal nicht. Das brauchen wir 11-Head für.
Und wenn man mit den Ausfällen ehrlich umgeht, dann liegt die Bahn nicht bei den 76,5 Pünktlichkeiten.
Das waren die angekündigten und auch nicht bei den 75, das ist der aktuelle Wert, sondern bei 72,5.
Mit jedem Prozent weniger wird es sehr viel unwahrscheinlicher, dass Leute ihre Anschlüsse kriegen.
Also unterschätzt das nicht, wenn das nochmal 2 Prozent weniger sind als sie behaupten oder 3. Das ist knackig.
76,5 ist schon armselig.
Damit möchte ich noch zu einem wichtigen Thema kommen, Erfolgskriterien in Unternehmen.
Wenn ihr als Unternehmen eure Erfolgskriterien schlecht setzt, dann schafft ihr Anreize, die das Unternehmen in eine unerwartete Richtung lenken.
Und hier haben wir ein Paradebeispiel dafür. Wenn die Bahn einen unpünktlichen Zug einfach spontan ausfallen lässt,
dann steht die nach ihrer eigenen Messmethode danach besser da und nicht schlechter, weil die Ausfälle einfach komplett zur Statistik fliegen.
Also müssen wir uns die Frage stellen, wo genau lohnt es sich für die Bahn am meisten, ein paar Ausfälle zu erzeugen,
um damit die Pünktlichkeitsstatistik zu pushen.
Es ist so paradox eigentlich, allein schon dieser Satz.
Ihr klatscht ja schon vorher. So kann ich nicht arbeiten.
Und die Lösung ist, am Ende und am Anfang von Fahrten, Züge fahren nämlich häufig dieselbe Strecke hin und her.
Und der hier fährt los. Bis hier ist alles gut gegangen.
Hier hat er dann satt Verspätung angesammelt. Das passiert.
Und an diesem Punkt ist zu erwarten, dass die letzten beiden Halte auch verspätet sein werden.
Und auch die ersten beiden Halte der Rückfahrt natürlich.
Das ist also schlecht für die Statistik. Also lassen wir die doch einfach ausfallen. Blasen wir ab.
Der Zug schmeißt die Fahrgäste raus, dreht an Ort und Stelle um und ist wieder pünktlich.
Und wer in den roten Stops einsteigen und aussteigen will, der steht halt mit leerem Blick am Gleis.
Aber die Verspätungsstatistik verbessert sich, denn die Ausfälle fallen ja einfach unter den Tisch.
Aber wie könnte man sowas messen?
Du guckst, welche Züge Verspätung haben. Und dann die nächsten.
Hamburg. Oh ja.
Also ganz einfach. Hier ist wieder eine Zugfahrt mit all ihren Stops.
Und die unterteilen wir jetzt einfach in drei Klassen.
Die frühen, mittleren und späte Stops. Die frühen und späten sind die ersten und letzten drei. Hier grau.
Und die mittleren sind der Rest. Und für diese drei Artenstops machen wir getrennte Auswertungen.
Wenn Ausfälle aufgrund technischen Betriebes entstehen, würde man ja erwarten, dass es am Start...
Was der Typ ist, auch immer bei der Bahn macht er.
...statistisch weniger Ausfälle gibt und dann werden das so über die Zeit mehr.
Und beim IC ist das auch genauso. Die Ausfälle steigen nach hinten an.
Und beim ICE dagegen fallen die ersten und letzten Stops häufiger aus.
Und das passt alles genau. Die scheinen die Dinge einfach hart zu wenden.
Und ich habe dieses Verhalten auch von zwei unabhängigen Quellen bestätigt bekommen.
Das ist halt hart, oder?
Und das war vor einigen Zeiten immer irgendwo klein in der Presse.
Also ich verrate hier keine Staatsgeheimnisse.
Und je nachdem, wenn man fragt, heißt dieses Vorgehen entweder nach unserem Verkehrsminister die Scheuerwende,
oder aber nach dem Bahnvorstand die Pofallerwende.
Das müsst ihr jetzt heute Abend beim Bier entscheiden, was ihr besser findet.
Jedenfalls ein weiterer Praxistipp.
Ist doch hart, oder?
Vorsicht am Anfang und am Ende eines ICE-Zuglaufs.
Die fallen gerne mal aus, bucht die nach Möglichkeit nicht.
Und aus Gründen der Neutralität muss ich dazu sagen, die Bahn hat natürlich ein Interesse daran,
dass das ganze Zugnetz ungefähr im Plan ist.
Also werden die sich denken, dass bei so einem Manöver nicht so viele Passagiere von den Ausfällen betroffen sind.
Dafür aber im weiteren Verlauf deutlich mehr Passagiere in pünktlichen Zug kriegen.
Ist eben deren Geschäftsentscheidung.
Es liegt mir fern, da jetzt von der Seitenlinie ohne tieferes Wissen altkluge Ratschläge zu erteilen.
Wir sind hier nicht auf Twitter.
Und was ich hier kritisieren möchte, ist aber, dass ausschließlich die positive Seite des Manövers
danach in der Statistik auftaucht und die Negative einfach verschwindet.
Das ist Halshoff von Arsch.
Das stört.
Wir wollen gar nicht wissen, wie viele Leute im Verkehrsministerium denen das abgekauft haben.
Wir hatten jetzt schon ein bisschen Praxistipps gesehen, die euch zu Hause beim Buchen vielleicht ein bisschen was bringen.
Vorsicht mit bestimmten Bahnhöfen.
Vorsicht mit ICEs im Allgemeinen.
ICEs.
Vorsicht mit ICEs im Sommer im Speziellen.
Vorsicht, wenn Züge schon lange unterwegs waren.
Vorsicht, wenn sie 40 Minuten oder mehr verspätet sind.
Und jetzt gerade Vorsicht mit ICEs am Anfang und am Ende der Fahrt wegen der Scheuerwänden.
Allein schon was man darauf achten muss.
Und ich würde jetzt mit euch noch jede Menge Standardkram machen, der sich irgendwie aus den Daten ergibt.
Top 10 Bahnhöfe oder Zuglinien nach Verspätung, Ausfällen und so weiter.
Aber das hilft doch nur wenigen, ganz ehrlich.
Also machen wir jetzt noch zwei Sachen.
Erstens machen wir unsere letzte große Sache mit den Bahndaten.
Und ich hoffe, dass ihr davon zumindest für ein paar Monate ganz konkret was habt.
Und danach würde ich mit euch gerne kurz über das ausklingende Jahrzehnt nachdenken.
Zuerst die Datensache.
Wenn ihr ein Bahnticket kauft, könnt ihr wählen.
Mit Starktickets seid ihr an exakt die Züge, die ihr gebucht habt, gebunden.
Oder ihr nehmt ein Flexticket, das ist deutlich teurer, aber dafür habt ihr keine Zugbindung.
Und interessant ist nun folgende Regel auf den Spartickets.
Wenn sie durch Verschulden der DB ihren Anschlusszug nicht erwischen
oder allgemein eine Verspätung von mehr als 20 Minuten erwartet werden muss,
wird die Zugbindung automatisch aufgehoben.
Und ich verstehe das so, dass ihr dann eigentlich ein Flexticket habt plötzlich.
Würde ich auch so verstehen.
Dann gucken wir mal auf den Prozentplatz der Stops, die entweder mehr als 20 Minuten zu spät waren
oder aber ausgefallen sind.
Und insgesamt sind das immerhin 12,4 Prozent.
Und wenn man jetzt diese Stops erwischt, dann verwandeln die einem vielleicht schon vor Abfahrt
ein preiswertes Sparticket in ein Flexticket.
Und das wäre doch total cool, wenn man die vorher wissen könnte.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Das kann man vorhersehbar machen.
Und komplett vorhersehen geht natürlich nicht, aber es gibt Züge, bei denen so was häufiger auftritt
und Bahnhöfe, bei denen so was häufiger auftritt.
Und es gibt auch Wochentage, bei denen so was häufiger auftritt.
Und hier ist ein Beispiel.
Les mal mit.
Das bedeutet beim Intercity 2221 ist an allen Halten bei Mainz Hauptbahnhof
an allen Mittwochen dieses Jahr mit 53 Prozent Wahrscheinlichkeit die Zugbindung aufgehoben.
Also von allen Stops, die ich dazu erfasst habe, waren 53 Prozent entweder mehr als 20 Minuten zu spät
oder sind ganz ausgefallen.
Und am Freitag das Ganze mit 50 Prozent.
Ich muss die Schreibweise so kurz machen und euch das so beibringen, das Lesen,
damit ich jetzt auf dem Platz sparen kann.
Euch schwandt vermutlich schon, was ich jetzt mache.
Also ich habe für euch die Kombination aus allen Wochentagen, allen Bahnhöfen und allen Fernzügen durchsucht
und habe dann nur die Kombination genommen, wo ich mindestens zehn Datenpunkte hatte,
damit das einigermaßen fundiert ist.
Und für die habe ich gemessen, bei wie viel Prozent die Zugbindung dieses Zuges an diesem Wochentag
an diesem Bahnhof gekillt wurde.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, ich will nur die ganz fiesen haben, wo das mit mindestens 50 Prozent der Fälle der Fall war.
Und herausgekommen sind fast 500 Kombinationen aus Wochentagen, Bahnhöfen und Zügen.
Hier sind sie.
Aber das ist nice.
Das ist echt geil.
Also ich würde, ich würde kein Flex-Ticket für teuer Geld kaufen,
wenn ich an einem dieser Bahnhöfe einsteige, aussteige oder umsteige an dem Wochentag mit diesem Zug.
Kauft ein Sparticket. Und für alle, die das jetzt nicht lesen könnten,
ich stelle den Foliensatz wieder irgendwie bei mir auf die Seite morgen oder so,
beachtet auch, dass die Daten irgendwann ungültig werden.
Ihr behaltet den Zug.
Fotografisches Gedächtnis direkt gemerkt.
Ich bin nicht schuld, wenn ihr unverhofft doch pünktlich zum Zug eintreten müsst,
weil die Kiste halt pünktlich ist.
Also bitte behandelt diese Daten, als wären sie mit Xerox-Geräten gescannt.
Und wenn ihr doch pünktlich da sein müsst, dann ist das ja auch ein gutes Zeichen,
weil es nichts anderes bedeutet, als dass die Bahn was verbessert.
Verbesserungen passieren nämlich durchaus.
Dieses Jahr wurde zum Beispiel die ECE-Trasse zwischen München und Berlin ausgebaut.
Da kann man jetzt unter vier Stunden zwischen beiden Städten hin und her fahren,
ohne den Zug zu wechseln.
Und wenn das rund läuft, ist das echt mal eine Alternative zum Flug.
Es ist also nicht alles schlecht.
Also ich hoffe auch, ich bin bei aller Kritik fair mit der Bahn umgegangen heute.
Ich bin jedenfalls, obwohl ich das alles gesehen habe, mit der Bahn zum Kongress gefahren
und werde das auch auf dem Rückweg machen.
Und für heute möchte ich damit die Bahnbetrachtung abschließen mit den Worten
Seid nett zur Bahn mit Ihren Fehlern.
Wir haben nur diese einen.
Und was bleibt?
Sie könnte besser sein.
Sie müsste eigentlich besser sein.
Da habe ich noch ein harter Karma schon gelaufen.
Das hier ist der letzte Vortrag, den ich in diesem Jahrzehnt halten werde.
Ich lasse euch jetzt mal ein paar Sekunden in Ruhe und wünsche mir,
dass jeder kurz darüber nachdenkt, was für ihn in diesem Jahrzehnt
die maßgebliche gesellschaftliche Entwicklung war.
Kann ich euch sagen.
Smartphones.
Glaube hat jeder fast.
Für mich ist es der Aufstieg der Empörten.
Und damit meine ich ausdrücklich jede politische Richtung.
Ich habe in diesem Jahrzehnt tausendmal an jeder Ecke gehört,
wie wichtig heutzutage technische, naturwissenschaftliche und analytische Skills
seien angeblich, mit anderen Worten Rationalität.
Auf der anderen Seite reicht es heute im öffentlichen Diskurs als Totschlagsargument,
wenn jemand empört ist.
Und ich finde das paradox.
Da hat er sowas von Recht.
Man kann nicht beide zweiteilig propagieren.
Der hat sowas von Recht.
Dass wir für das jetzt kommende Jahrzehnt zu einer Kultur finden,
in der es ungern gesehen wird, einfach nur alles Mögliche anzuprangern
und in der es ganz umgekehrt bewundert wird, wenn man sich die Datenlage anguckt
und sich gegenseitig präsentiert mit seinem Kontrahenten
und sich dann zusammensetzt.
Und wer soll das starten, wenn nicht wir hier?
Verlassen wir uns nicht auf die Medien, denn die leben vom Aufruhr,
auch wenn es positive Gegenbeispiele gibt.
Verlassen wir uns nicht auf irgendwelche Stars, die leben von Likes
und die kriegt man am besten durch Zuschauenspitzung.
In der Regel sind die Teil des Problems.
Verlassen wir uns nicht auf Politiker, die achten wegen der Shitstorm-Kultur
nur noch darauf, bis zur nächsten Wahl nicht anzuecken
und zu viele von denen haben ohnehin niemals außerhalb der Politik gearbeitet.
Was soll da schon kommen?
Und das ist der Grund, warum ich das hier mache.
Ich versuche euch zu inspirieren, eure eigenen Analysen zu strittigen Themen anzustellen.
Denn in meinen letzten Vorträgen, meinen beiden hier,
habt ihr ein paar Instinkte davon bekommen, wie das geht.
Und ich hoffe, ich habe euch bewiesen, dass das absolut keine Raketenwissenschaft ist.
Und ich frage noch mal, wer soll das machen, wenn nicht wir hier?
Wenn wir es gemeinsam schaffen, dass wenigstens manche,
die heute echt nichts Wesseres zu tun haben, als sich im Internet
einfach mal Brain einschalten, im nächsten Jahrzehnt
zur engagierten Analyse übergehen und dabei auch anerkennen,
wenn was rauskommt, das sie vorher nicht gedacht hätten,
dann haben wir gesellschaftlich unglaublich viel gewonnen.
Heute Abend stehe ich hier in einem Saal mit 5.000 Leuten, voll belegt,
da sitzen sie noch neben der Tribüne,
mit 5.000 Leuten, die sich am Samstagabend
zwischen Weihnachten und Silvester hier hinsetzen,
also da, wo die allermeisten Menschen einfach gar nichts tun
und sich die Flasche Wein an den Hals anschließen.
Und warum tun die 5.000 Leute das?
Um einen Statistikvortrag zu hören.
Ja, das gibt mir Hoffnung.
Ich werde glücklich heimfahren, da kann die Bahn mit mir machen,
was sie will, und ich bedanke mich, dass ihr hier wart
und wünsche euch ein schönes neues Jahrzehnt.
Das war ein schönes Schlusswort.
Sehr gut.
Die Frage, ob er pünktlich heimkommt mit der Bahn,
jetzt haben wir das für was anderes.
Top Vortrag.
Und im Schlusswort kann ich echt nur
uneingeschränkt recht gehen.
Ich habe es ja erst vor ein paar Tagen wieder auf Twitter gesehen,
über was sich alles empört wird.
Vielen lieben Dank.
Wow.
Auch von mir nochmal herzlichen Dank.
Super Vortrag, wie immer.
Super lustig.
Dankeschön, David, dass du das immer wieder machst.
Wir haben noch ein bisschen Zeit für Fragen.
Bitte an die Mikrofone.
Es gibt vier, fünf Stück hier im Saal.
Wir fangen mit Mikrofon eins an.
Du hast ja damit angefangen, dass du
der Fairness halber die Pünktlichkeitsdefinition
der Bahn von sechs Minuten höchstens gesetzt hast.
Hast du aus purer Neugier mal
Sachen durchgerechnet mit Pünktlichkeitsdefinitionen,
die sie sinnvoller anfühlen?
Das sind ja nicht gleich die 30 Sekunden aus Japan.
Da kann man sich streiten, welchen Wert man setzt.
Also das sieht natürlich...
Das sieht dann so aus, dass wenn man das eng zieht,
am Schluss natürlich alle Züge verspätet sind.
Jeder hat mal irgendwie eine Minute.
Was ich gemacht habe, war,
ich habe mal eine Reibungslosmetrik gesetzt.
Reibungslos habe ich gesagt, das ist alles,
was mit der Reibungslosmetrik gesetzt ist.
Nicht ausgefallen und kein Gleiswechsel,
weil das geht mir immer unglaublich auf die Nerven,
wenn ich dann mit Koffer einmal hoch und runter.
Das waren dann irgendwie 60%.
Aber nagel mich jetzt darauf nicht fest.
Ich habe es jetzt nicht im Kopf, aber es waren deutlich weniger.
Ich glaube, es war bei 60% diese Pünktlichkeit.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, welches Mikro er ist.
Aber ich habe jetzt die Sendingsovations an.
Es gab viele Leute, die darauf hingewiesen haben,
dass für ausgefallene Züge oft Ersatzfahrten bereitgestellt werden.
Wie taucht das bei dir in der Statistik auf?
Das taucht bei mir gar nicht auf.
Da war ich mir auch nicht komplett sicher.
Wenn die komplett neue Fahrten haben,
die gar nicht im Plan aufgetaucht waren,
dann werde ich die vermutlich nicht drin haben.
Deswegen kann ich es nicht genau sagen.
Ich weiß jedenfalls, dass die Kollegen
beim Spiegel eine ähnliche Analyse hatten auf einem kleineren Datensatz.
Da war das auch jenseits der 4%-Ausfallquote.
Wenn es falsch ist, stimmt es zumindest über ein.
Es kann sein, dass sie drin sind. Ich bin mir nicht völlig sicher.
Danke. Mikrofon 5, bitte mit einer Frage.
Vielen Dank für diesen sehr interessanten Vortrag.
Es war bestimmt auch super viel Aufwand, das alles zu analysieren.
Nach den ständigen Provesen traue ich mich auch fast gar nicht,
eine kritische Frage zu stellen.
Sie hatten ja ziemlich am Anfang einen Slide zu den Bahnhöfen,
die den Zügen Verspätungen hinzufügen.
Oder wo die Züge vielleicht Verspätungen aufholen.
Aber es ist nicht viel eher so,
dass die Strecken zwischen den Bahnhöfen dazu führen,
dass die Züge Verspätungen bekommen und nicht die Bahnhöfe selber.
Wäre das dann nicht auch richtig?
Zwischen welchen Bahnhöfen kriegen die Züge am meisten Verspätungen?
Das ist eine exakt sehr geile Frage.
Ich habe bestimmt was gekifft.
Diese Auswertung war in der Tat ein bisschen tricky, genau aus dem Grund.
Vielleicht ist der Bahnhof Frankfurt die Verspätung gar nicht schuld,
sondern die Gleise beim Reihen und Rausfahren zum Beispiel.
Deswegen messe ich die Verspätungsänderung
von dem Streckensegment vor dem Bahnhof
und dem Streckensegment nach dem Bahnhof.
Der jeweilige Bahnhof kriegt dann den Durchschnitt,
damit ich genau von diesem Effekt geheilt werde.
Dann habe ich einen sehr guten Durchschnittswert.
Wer immer etwas dazu fügt im Schnitt,
der wird auch selber etwas dazu beitragen.
Oder beide Streckensegmente dahin sind schlecht.
Also immer.
Dann ist das auch für mich ein Bahnhofproblem.
Genau genommen, was ich analysiere,
ist das Problem des Bahnhofs und der Umgebung darum herum.
Danke für diese Frage.
Vielen Dank für die Antwort.
Da habe ich mir lange durch Gedanken zugemacht,
ob ich da jetzt einfach nur die Änderung der Verspätung nehme.
Aber das hätte ich mir selbst als Statistik zerrissen,
wenn ich da einen bei erwischt hätte.
Aber deswegen perfekt, dass es aufgefallen ist.
Wir haben nur gute Menschen hier, sehr schön.
Wir nehmen Mikrofon 3, wechseln mal die Seite bitte.
Ich muss immer ein bisschen suchen.
Entschuldigt, wenn ich euch nicht... Da hinten ist er.
Du hattest am Anfang angeprangert,
dass die Ausfälle nicht zu Verspätungen zählen.
Und hattest am Anfang dieses Leid,
wo der Berliner Flughafen immer ausfällt.
Und es gibt vielleicht auch andere Bahnhöfe,
die umgebaut werden,
oder wo Plan mehr nicht ausfallen.
Hast du die rausgerechnet?
Nach meiner Information sind die Stops gar nicht im Plan.
Das sieht so aus.
Und dann habt ihr die Änderungen.
Wenn da was ausfällt, ist da eine Cancellation-Time drin.
Nämlich der Zeitpunkt des Ausfalls.
Da kann man auch noch schöne Auswertungen machen.
Das würde in den Daten, nach meiner Kenntnis,
anders aussehen, wobei ich das auch nur reverse-engineere.
Die dokumentieren nicht alles.
Ich weiß nicht, wer von euch vorhin in den Bahn-API-Vortrag drin war.
Da habe ich letztes Jahr geguckt mit der Bahn-API.
Also auch das mit dem Körnchen Salz.
Danke, wir nehmen Mikrofon 2.
Ich bin auch Bahnfahrer.
Aber nach meiner Erfahrung ist der Regionalverkehr
viel häufiger verspätet als der Fernverkehr.
Und deshalb die Frage,
wann gibt es die Analyse für den Nahverkehr?
Wo kommst du denn her?
Ich lebe südlich von Stuttgart.
Ich habe die Nahverkehrs-Bahnhöfe nicht runtergeladen.
Was ich aber habe,
ist natürlich sämtlicher Nahverkehr,
der über alle Fernbahnhöfe gefahren ist.
Und die sind strategisch gut verteilt.
Sodass ich da in der Tat auch für den Nahverkehr was sehen kann.
Vielleicht mache ich meine Pünktlichkeit
von dem Nahverkehr,
der in den Fernverkehrs-Bahnhöfen vorbeigefahren ist.
Dann muss ich das als Tabelle auf meine Webseite stellen.
Dann kannst du gucken.
Vielen Dank.
Wir haben noch ein kleines bisschen Zeit.
Mikrofon 6, die andere Seite.
Vielen Dank für den Vortrag.
Aus München kommt,
haben wir eine chronisch schlechte S-Bahn.
Ich habe mich auch gefragt,
ist der Regionalverkehr noch mal unterschiedlich zum Nahverkehr?
Oder ist die Münchner S-Bahn zu spät?
Vielleicht über eure großen Bahnhöfe.
Ihr habt zwei oder drei richtig dicke.
München-Ost, München und noch irgendeinen.
Dann habe ich die drin.
Ich würde dann auch in der Frage auftauchen.
Diese über 90 % Pünktlichkeit im Regionalverkehr,
die sind für Bahn- und Subunternehmen vermutlich.
Ich muss mal gucken.
Aber die anderen habe ich ja drin.
Vielleicht beziehe ich die einfach mal mit ein
in die regionale Analyse.
Das könnte interessant sein.
Ich bin gespannt drauf.
Wir nehmen euch beide heute Nacht.
Auf den Slides 80 und 84
war dargestellt,
wie die Bahn die Teilausfälle rausrechnet aus der Statistik.
Aber müssten nicht die gesamten Züge rausgerechnet werden
wäre das die Statistik.
Und dann wäre die Statistik
dementsprechend noch besser.
Jetzt habe ich meinen Powerpoint abgeschossen.
Er macht es mit Powerpoint?
Das hätte ich nicht verwartet.
Es ist schön Granular für Stops zu rechnen.
Angenommen, das ganze System würde so funktionieren,
dass alle Züge auf der Hälfte ihrer Stops
pünktlich sind und auf der anderen Hälfte unpünktlich.
Dann wäre das doch halb pünktlich.
Wir arbeiten ja feiner als auf der Granularität von Zügen.
Aber es werden Teilausfälle auch rausgerechnet.
Ist es dann wirklich nur der ausgefallene Stopp?
Soweit ich weiß, ist es nur der ausgefallene Stopp.
Dann noch Mikrofon 1.
Vielen Dank für den Talk.
Meine Frage geht in die Richtung
von den Käffern, an denen sich die Bahn messen lässt.
Es hat darauf hingewiesen,
dass die Ausfallrate da vielleicht nicht gut sein könnte.
Es wäre schön, wenn sie drin wäre.
Genau, wenn sie drin wäre.
Eine andere Sache, die da reinspielt,
ist, wie hoch die Ziele sind,
wie hoch die Ziele sind,
aber es gibt keine Daten.
Das geht durch die Presse.
Ich mache eine Markdown-Editor.
Man könnte die Züge pünktlicher machen,
dadurch, dass man jedem Zug eine Stunde mehr Zeit gibt,
dieselbe Strecke zu fahren.
Die ist bei der Bahn relativ eng im Vergleich zu Flugzeugen.
Deswegen sind die Flugzeuge häufiger pünktlich.
Oder ungefähr pünktlich.
Bei der Bahn ist alles sehr eng getaktet.
Vor allem sind die Sachen interdependent.
Wenn einer auf der Strecke liegen bleibt,
haben alle dahinter ein Problem.
Das sorgt für die Fragilität, die wir sehen.
Hast du vor, die Analyse in weiteren Jahren vorzuführen,
um in die Richtung etwas zu sehen?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Zum einen habe ich Arbeit und Familie.
Warum sagt er nicht gleich, dass alles bei der Bahn sehr scheiße ist?
Hast du nicht das Schlusswort gehört von ihm?
Dann gucke ich mal, was ich noch rauskriege.
Geht es nicht darum zu sagen, dass die Bahn scheiße ist?
Sondern ihm geht es zu sagen,
was Sache ist?
Ich denke nicht, weil ich das nicht darf.
Am Ende hat die Bahn dafür das Copyright.
Viel mehr Copyright-Verstoß ginge gar nicht,
aber sie sucht bei der Bahn
die Timetable-API.
Dann ladet ihr das einfach runter.
Es geht.
Ich habe die Maus aus dem Bild.
Die Maus ist aber wieder da.
Herzlichen Dank.
Danke schön.
Es war ein echt guter Vortrag.
Wenn ihr den Saal verlässt,
schaut mal rechts und links von euch,
nehmt den Müll mit, den ihr hinterlassen habt,
oder klaut den von eurem Nachbarn.
Ich muss sagen,
ein extrem guter Vortrag,
guter Präsentator,
Kommentator, Vorträger,
Vortrag-Haltender,
inhaltlich auch extrem geil.
Das Schlusswort war genau richtig.
So muss man das beenden.
Das ist einer der besten Vorträge,
die ich in letzter Zeit gesehen habe.
Welcher Vortrag war das?
Bahn-Mining von David Griesel.
Die Comedy-Nummer am Anfang zähle ich nicht
zum Beitrag davor.
Ich bin jetzt auf dem Ende.
Aber der Rest war wirklich...
Eats-Clap.
Warum habe ich eigentlich kein Clap-Emote?
Ich habe nur Eats, aber kein Clap.
Weil wir es ganz kurz davon hatten im Stream.
Ich zeige das noch mal, was ich für ein Programm
für Präsentationen verwende.
Ich habe ja gesagt, ich verwende keinen PowerPoint.
Ich verwende natürlich, was er will.
Mit PowerPoint kann man auch gute Präsentationen machen.
Ich will auch nicht sagen, dass meine Präsentationen
dadurch besser werden.
Und schon gar nicht so gut wie die, die wir gesehen haben.
Ich verwende das hier.
Ich weiß, es ist archiviert.
Das ist ein Markdown-Editor
mit ein bisschen Sündagserweiterung
in der Präsentation.
Und am Ende generiere ich einen PDF daraus
und mache das PDF einfach in Fullscreen, um gut ist.
Hat den Vorteil, läuft einfach auch überall drauf.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Leute.
Also wenn es nicht noch mal ganz wichtig ist,
was hier irgendwie los werden wollte,
würde ich es mir geben.
Ganz wichtig, guck mal da.
Da erkläre ich.
Surf Jelly verwende ich so gut wie nicht.
Kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Das war echt guter Beitrag.
Also echt gut ab.
Der kann es.
Na denn, Leute, sehen wir uns morgen früh.
Was sagt man, Max?
Ich glaube, du hast deine Meinung zum Beitrag noch nicht gesagt.
War doch super Vortrag.
Hab ich doch gesagt.
Also, wir sehen uns morgen früh wieder.
Zur üblichen Uhrzeit.
Zum allwöchentlichen
Sonntag-Aufwachstream.
Also, bis morgen früh, macht es gut.
See you.